To one. Boom. Andre ward, ladies and gentlemen, Hawaii brother. I'm good man.
How you doing? Thank you very much for doing this, man. I'm a big fan,
so I was very excited to do this. Appreciate you have me.
You did it in terms of like,
if you're a young fighter and you've got aspirations, what do you want to do?
You want to be an Olympic gold medalist?
You want to win multiple world titles to division world champion and you're
retired undefeated. You, you're the one, you're like a unicorn man.
You have rare dude because you were tired at 35, right? 33 33.
That's crazy. Like you're in the peak of your athletic abilities and you go,
you know what? I did enough. I'm out. Yeah,
I made it sound. It sounds all neat and buttoned up. Uh, but it wasn't,
it wasn't that easy.
Like I didn't know how things were going to go throughout the course of my
career. Um, but for whatever reason, like I always, even as a young kid,
and I'm talking 10 years old, like I had this thought like, you know,
I don't want to end up like a lot of fighters end up. Like I seen my go high,
really high, and then all of a sudden they come crashing down.
Like they start well, but they don't end well. That's what,
that's what drew me to Roy Jones jr um,
country boy has swag and he'd always talk about himself in the third person.
He'd be like, man, you know, Roy Jones, I don't, you know,
I don't love this sport. Like that, man. I'm gonna get in and get out.
I'm just special at it and I'm gonna be fishing on my farm one, you know,
one day in Pensacola, Florida. And I was like, man, this dude is different.
Fighters don't talk like that.
So he was the first one that gave me the thought of getting in and getting out.
And then again, I just, I just studied it throughout the course of my career,
even other athletes and entertainers. Like I just, I was enamored by it.
So that was always a goal.
Just as much as I wanted to win a gold medal world championship.
I wanted to leave on top when people were asking, why are you leaving? Yeah.
It's so difficult to make that decision though for something.
Roy Jones jr didn't even make that decision.
He said he was going to do it and then,
I mean he had some rough knockouts late in his career.
It's hard to watch that some of them that people even didn't even see. Yeah.
Yeah. Heartbreaking. Yeah.
Especially if you followed him and supported him like I have. Especially if,
you know, his decision was based on Gerald McClellan. A lot of it was
Gerald McClellan for people who don't know was a murderer man.
He was a Savage light heavyweight, but he caught,
he was cutting a lot of weight and um, you know,
he wound up having a serious brain injury and,
and in that Epic fight with Nigel badge, which is an amazing, amazing fight.
Would Ben got off the deck? It looked like the fight was over. Yup.
Cause Gerald McClellan would just Merck people, man. Absolutely.
A truck like a prototypical Cronk destroyer, you know, the right hand,
Ooh, tall, strong as fuck, super aggressive, knockout, striker,
and for whatever reason, Roy, um, decided, you know what?
Let's just keep doing it. Fuck it.
So a lot of different reasons why people do that, man.
I just didn't want to be one of them. Simple, simply put. Um,
but it's like the retirement is coming up on two years, September 21st. Um,
it's harder than I thought it was going to be.
One of the most hardest things I've ever had to do.
But one of the most rewarding and the way I reconcile it in my brain is that,
okay, at some point I'm going to have to do this.
At some point I'm gonna have to face the emotions and the pool to come back.
And you know,
trying to figure out if your body can still do it and just all the different
things you go through, whether I'm in my prime or whether I'm 40,
45 years old. So you can't avoid it.
It's just when do you want to take take on that task?
So you retired at 33 35 now. So God damn man, you're right there.
I mean you've like four more years to be, unless you're Bernard Hopkins,
then you have another decade. But to Bernard's credit, he started late.
He did when our started at 20 some years old and greater for state prison. Yes,
I started at nine years old.
Well also Bernard developed this insane discipline while I was in prison that
the hardships of prison were so awful.
The feeling of being locked up and contained, that he fucked up his life.
He was so bound and determined to become something special than me.
He's so disciplined. Yeah. Well even beyond that,
like he opened up his eyes and he looked at the landscape and he realized that
most fighters are not disciplined. Most fighters,
they liked the idea of being a champion. They liked the idea of winning,
you know, championships and what that brings,
not just the championship of what the championships and the money brings the
ladies, the, you know, the party and all the stuff. And he said,
I'm going to do it a different way.
Like these guys are out gaining weight 20 pounds in between fights.
I'm gonna live like a Spartan. He under,
he got the revelation and he just stuck to it. Yeah, he ate clean.
He lived a clean life and he thought so disobey. He fought so smart.
He was one of the best defensive fighters ever just,
and people didn't like that style man.
He would pop you and grab you poppy and grab you and people get frustrated.
They would get out of composure and they would start doing the things that maybe
they shouldn't have done and then he would capitalize those things.
I remember when he fought Trinidad man, I mean now
these Trinidad was a killer and I love Tito. I do too. I mean, he was a killer.
I got a chance to see Tito fight live in Vegas once. It was amazing,
but when Bernard started putting it on him, I was like, wow,
this is first of all you, this is a like a legitimate middleweight finding guys,
really a welterweight and this is also a really special fighter who just figures
people out. He fought Tito in New York city in Madison square garden,
which teaches little Puerto Rico like, you know,
I think it was the week of the Puerto Rican day parade lights.
And previously to that fight in Puerto Rico,
Bernard Hopkins took the Puerto Rican flag, threw it down, caused a Malay,
had to run out of there and get snatched out of the arena wherever they were.
Having a press conference get thrown on the plane,
like the beef was real and a to be able to like,
like perform under that kind of pressure. Unreal.
One of my favorite fights when he was running away from the crowd in Puerto Rico
and you realize like, Oh my God, he's on his own here.
Like literally people were trying to kill him,
but w w what's even crazier is he knew that was gonna happen. Like he knew,
okay, is getting ready to happen in three, two, one three to flag down.
And it was on. Oh man. But it worked. First of all,
it got so many people to pay attention to that fight. And then too, it got,
you know, it got t-tell emotional. If he lost that fight,
he was back to the back of the bus. If he wins the fight, which he did,
he moves on and become great on. Yeah, he moves onto greatness. You know,
it's interesting when you watch his style as well, that very technical,
very disciplined style versus Roy style,
which was so athletic and explosive and very unusual with that lead left hook
that he would fire off more than a jam. I mean,
Roy had a crazy style and then when you watch Roy out point Bernard early.
Yep.
But then Bernard comes back later in his career and really kinda like shut Roy
down and showed like when the athleticism starts to slip away a little bit.
Roy is normal. He's a human. He's a human. Yeah.
Whereas Bernard was still this incredibly disciplined,
very well schooled boxer was a real good lesson for fighters to see the deal.
Like this is why you use the fundamentals. This is why you fight correctly.
You can get away with being Roy Jones jr,
but Roy Jones jr with his physical gifts.
I feel like he could've got away with fighting discipline too.
He could've got away with fighting technically, but you know,
he just chose to fight his way. It worked for a long time until it didn't work.
But it worked better than anybody. I mean,
it was amazing to watch in the day when he was on top. Yeah. You know,
when he was knocking out Virgil Hill with body shots and putting his hands
behind his back and knocking dudes out. I mean,
how was the guy fell in love with, you know,
he could've, he could've,
he could've gone and had a full career and rode off in the sunset and been in
Pensacola fishing, hunting,
doing whatever he does and still not really been super fundamentally sound.
But I mean,
after he beat John Ruiz for the heavyweight championship of the world, uh,
and I had been going to multiple Roy fights leading up to that heavyweight
fight. Antonio Tarver, who I have a lot of respect for it, you know,
they were rivals in Florida when they were young. Um,
Antonio was following Roy around trying to get him to notice.
I'm trying to get him to take a fight and our members are clear as day.
And the post-fight press conference after Roy became the heavyweight champion of
the world after being the middleweight champion, starting at one 60 10,
uh, Antonio, Tara interrupted the press conference. He said, Roy Jones,
you've been ducking me. You can run in. He's going on and on and on.
Roy looks at Tarver and gives him the attention that he's been after.
And he said, Whoa. He said, I'm a whoop you. I'm, I'm gonna whip you.
We don't make that fight happen. And at that moment I'm thinking like, no rule.
Like, no, don't do it. You're the heavyweight champion of the world.
Tarver was still light, heavy weight and sure enough,
Roy went down or stripped off 25 pounds a muscle that he had built up with
Mackey shields stone to get ready for the heavyweight fight. Went down there,
fought a close fight, but he didn't look like himself.
Took the rematch net out even after the first fight with Tarver.
May you run for the Hills?
You know what? I beat him. I wasn't myself. I'm going back up,
took the rematch and then got knocked out. Yeah I didn't,
that's where I thought the re the first fight was earlier.
Now my brain scrambled here cause I thought that that was immediately after the
Ruiz fight that he got knocked out. Yeah, it was he, when he went back down.
Yes. So Ruiz, light heavyweight went down,
fought target with the first time they fought the rematch and then got knocked
out two times in a row.
They fought two times in a row and then they ended up fighting a third time,
like way down the road. Did they really?
I didn't even know they fought a third time in Florida.
The loss of the weight was a terrible idea.
And also let's be realistic about how we put that weight on is most likely there
was some Mexican supplements involved and if you're going to put that kind of
bulk on, you know, I mean, I don't know. Yeah. I'm going to say Roy Jones,
one of my heroes. Not disrespect. No, I hear you.
And I've heard people say stuff like that, but like that's my guy. I hear you.
I'm a kid, so I'm like, no. Again, I know. I get it.
I'm believing that it was just Roy Mackey shale stone and hard work.
I believe it is. It's possible. It's possible. But I mean, what did you like?
He was like 33 34 if he was, he was somewhere on it.
Very hard to put 25 pounds of muscle on it. Well,
it didn't really see he cut weight to make the light heavyweight limit. Right.
So you got to think he was probably like one 85 one one 90 probably. Yeah.
And so he really only gained maybe 10 15 pounds still. Yeah,
he was leaning as fuck. Yeah. He was pretty lazy though, too. Roy had it,
bro had that kind of bill. Oh, he was country strong. Very muscular. I mean,
he had crazy biceps and no tribe steps.
It was all just whipping last until the trial was weird. Right.
He had a crazy body. I didn't notice that dude. His, his body was very unusual.
The way he was built. Like he was all biceps. It was just whipping. You know?
He's just from whipping punches. [inaudible] shots. Yeah, no, he was phenomenal.
You got a picture of him, Jamie? Yeah. Oh, the TVs are out there. That's my guy.
No, I listen, I'm a gigantic Roy Jones jr fan. But I mean, I feel like that's,
there's one example right there. You see how gigantic his biceps are,
but you see it almost more while he's fighting.
I mean really had like a body built a hook.
You know what if Jones remained heavyweight, I mean, look,
he was so God damn fast as,
I mean John Ruiz just was Wiffen at air in that fight.
Most thing about them after the Ruiz fight is, you know,
we had the same manager, James Prince. There was a Tyson fight on the table.
Uh, and I believe I'm accurate when I say this.
It was somewhere around 40 million guaranteed. Whoa.
There's an upside to you. Stay at heavyweight, keep the weight on it.
Tyson wasn't quite Tyson at that time. Was still dangerous,
but wasn't quite Tyson. I think they were working toward it.
From what I've heard, Roy wanted more money. James Prince was like, bro,
take this 40 million. There's going to be an upside.
Is you in my ties and Roy Jones and Mike Tyson. Roy somehow said, Nope.
The fight will be there later on down the road. Put his attention toward it.
Antonio Tarver the rest is history. Wow. I'm kinda glad I didn't fight Tyson.
I wanted to see him fight Tyson and ride off in a sunset. Well, no, mass.
One more. Wow. Yeah, but he, I don't think he would have re,
I don't think Roy was ever really gonna ride off in the sunset.
He likes being Roy Jones jr.
So Mike Tyson Jones head 2003 fight card,
2000 T is that what around when he fought gelada they were supposed to start at
HBO paper view and they were supposed to be the first fight on it.
What happened?
Go to a Mike Tyson's Wikipedia did his record cause I think that was around the
time where he fought gelada he was still merkin people.
I mean he wasn't the Mike Tyson of, you know,
the later years he was still, I don't think Tyson fuck a lot of Diddy. Oh yeah,
he stopped him. Yeah. Gelada left the ring. He, he dropped him and hurt him.
Yeah. And GLAAD was like, fuck, this is his trainer called him a coward.
They use yelling, screaming.
When he hit him with one punch and dropped him and go out. I was like fuck this.
And he broke something in his neck. He broke his face and something in his neck.
Yeah. You gotta look three years before this? I was 2000 Oh, okay.
You never seen that? I probably did. I don't know.
I don't remember him fighting Tyson. Yeah. Gelada left the ring. He dropped his,
he says, well R T D what does that stand for? Retired.
Cause he quit. Yeah. And so the next dude too. Yeah,
like Tyson was last thing I remember there was a lot as his fights were ready to
go. Oh, those were Carlo blow. That's amazing. I remember gelada it was crazy.
He just decided to keep punching them in the deck.
Like I never saw anything like that in my life.
Like he fought him well in the first fight, but was hitting him.
He kept hitting them low.
Like whenever things would go bad for him looking for a way out,
he would just look for way out. And that's what he did with Tyson. Yeah.
Tyson dropped him. See if he could pull that up,
pull up the the Kao cause Tyson hit him with like a perfect right hand boom.
Dropped him and go out and got up. I was like fuck this.
His corner was screaming at him and he literally just climbed out of the ropes
and said, see ya just walked back to the dressing room. Some was off. Look,
a lot of man, definitely some was off. Well he was crazy.
Like he had done a lot of crazy street shit too and been with all of his bar
fights and stuff like that too. Like he went down,
he'd just quit after the second round. You can find out I'm watching the video.
I don't see it. We'll pull on so we could watch it.
What are you watching by yourself?
You're still trying to interrupt the conversation. Yeah, he went down, man.
I remember the fight very clearly.
He hit him with a clean right hand open around one here. Show it yo.
He was the one round fight. Two out fight.
I think he went down in the first [inaudible]. Here it is. Boom. When there,
right? Yeah, so gelada went down and at the end,
I think it was in between rounds. It was when he decided to bail.
I think that's why it's after the second here.
This is the second ending and he quits here. Guys come in.
Yeah. He's just like, no. Well we'd have to watch a little thing.
I remember that bro.
It was the right hand and liquor stores and everybody goes like, fuck you.
I'm out of here. He knew something was wrong too, and he had,
I think he had a fractured orbital and I believe there was something wrong with
his neck too. I get broke. A bone in his neck. I don't know.
Badass Andrew gelada for you man. Yeah. He was crazy. Yeah, it was some,
it was some offered him, I don't know. Whatever happened to him, you know?
I don't know. Probably not good. I hope. I hope. I hope he got some help.
You know what I mean? It's, you know,
when you think about a career as a heavyweight fight or two and all the heavy
blows at dot.
Chi took whatever mental problems he might've had were certainly compounded by
didn't help. No, no, no, no. You know, you,
you had an amazing career.
But one of the things that I think maybe people aren't as aware of is makes your
career even more incredible is that you fought for a long time with a bad
shoulder. Like if you go back and wants to crawl frosh fight.
I watched that getting ready for this. I watched it again.
You boxed the shit out of him with mostly your left hand. Yeah. It was crazy.
Yeah. 12 years old toward my subscapularis.
Um, which is 50 is responsible for 50% of the strength and the rotator,
um, didn't really know it at the time. We were told, Hey, he's too young.
You know, he shouldn't have surgery, just rehab it. Wrong advice.
Found that out, you know, 10 years later. But we just rehabbed it with,
you know, bands and strengthening exercises. But we never had surgery,
so that was always kind of my Achilles heel man. Like I,
there's been plenty of fights where I just fought one handed because it didn't
feel strong. It didn't feel like safe. I feel like anytime I would throw it,
it could pop out of the socket. Like that's how it felt.
So it had popped out before. It had not, Oh, I could, um,
got it fixed right around 2013 and, and it wasn't a hundred,
but it was better and I was able to finish out the rest of my career.
So it still not a hundred now. It's not a hundred, but I'll take it. Yeah,
I'll take it bro. Like I probably gained about 30, 40% with that surgery.
Like they grabbed it because the subscapularis was loose. It wasn't attached,
but it wasn't atrophied. It was still like a fat thriving muscle.
Just wasn't attached. My doctor was like, Whoa,
like is this ever popped out of the socket,
Dr. Michael Dillingham and in San Francisco? I was like, nah. He was like,
how like your shoulder capsule was like shot. The subscap is hanging. He said,
well, the good news is it's still a thriving muscle. Let's get it attached.
Pull me attached it like a four hour surgery, something like that.
One of those surgeries that you're not guaranteed to come out of the same, um,
and you had to wait for a month or so to see if the surgery took,
like if everything would mend and kind of get, you know, kind of gets stronger.
It took man. And like I said, I'll finish out the rest of my career strong. Wow.
So how long was the rehab? Probably about eight months. So you went from,
it was about 2012 to 2015 where you didn't fight very often.
Is that, was that very 10 frequently? Yeah.
Was that because of the combination of a lawsuit? Uh, and the injury? Yeah.
It's kinda like back to back blows.
So for eight months you're rehabbing it and just still like,
when did you know that for sure you're gonna be able to come back,
you kind of turn a corner and rehab, you know, three, three month Mark,
you know, four month Mark. You kinda realize that dude. Like, I'm, I'm,
I'm good. Like I'm not where I need to be, but like I'm, I'm headed there.
So probably about that time,
about halfway through you realize that you're going to be okay.
It's just gonna take some time to fully get the strength back.
But even my next fight against Edwin Rodriguez,
like I still didn't throw it and I didn't realize I didn't throw it until I
watched the tape. I watched the tape, I was like, Hey,
you still just like a one hand that affair.
And then after that thing about injuries is weird.
Like that 12 month period for me has always been like, just like the sweet spot.
So I got to that 12 month period with the shoulder and all of a sudden my
overhand right came back, hadn't thrown over here, right. In 10 years, you know,
my, the power am my right uppercut came back online,
told this is getting better. So after that,
then you started to see that thing flying and started whistling.
And ironically enough, my last fight,
that was the punch that started all the trouble for Sergey Kovalev.
Well it's interesting because you were so successful with one hand,
you know,
it makes you wonder like w how goddamn good would you have been if you had two
hands or was it your left hand was so educated.
One had to be had to be, but one of the things you were so good at man was a,
I don't have to tell you, you know, this was uh,
using your jab to shut down southpaw fighters shut down their jab and counter,
you know, and you just had that,
you had like extra juice with your left hand because you used it so much.
I had to like when you have one hand or one arm that that functions really well,
like you learned to make that thing great. Like, you know,
you overcompensate and that's what that left hand was overcompensation because I
didn't have the right hand to fall back on, you know,
but the whole South pole thing,
shout out to my boy Nick and ideas like in all the work we've done in camp,
like those guys got me ready for a lot and my South park opponents like you
know, midway through and toward the end of my career.
So a lot of work with those guys. And specifically Nate,
at a certain point I started working with Nick because he was doing other things
but Nate man and the volume and having to like deal with the awkwardness and the
height and the reach and like that got me ready for Chad Dawson. That's amazing.
How's my boy? Yeah, he's a tough dude man. You know,
watching him come back after three years out of the game and beat pedis like
that. I shot him a message. I was like, bro, you a bad man. Bad man,
like three years. Really. He's a bad man. Well,
I'm just happy that the UFC is finally recognizing the love and support that guy
has from the fans too. Because for whatever reason,
they were so high on Conor McGregor and all these other people. They didn't see.
One of the reasons why the Conor fight was so big was because of Nate Diaz.
They DHEAS is a fucking star. When he,
when they put his face on the screen for the Pettis fight,
I mean the arena erupted. It was chaos. They went nuts. Yeah,
I mean it, I don't know why they couldn't see it. I mean, Connor obviously was,
you know,
he was a little bit different and he brought what he brought to the table,
but probably would've been a good thing to try to balance them both out,
show love to, to Nate. But you know, he was like the rebel child, you know,
you say whatever came to his mind and you know, that the powers that beat,
I don't like that. Um, I think he was a little overshadowed by his brother too,
because you know, when for awhile there's a superstar, there's something about,
I mean, and especially like his brother when he was fighting in strike force in
particular was one of the best fighters in the world. He was just amazing.
And then, you know, like, especially like, um, you know,
during like his title reign, like when he was at, at,
at his peak and when he's fighting in strike force,
but for whatever reason they just, you know,
Nate just flew under the radar until that kind of McGregor fight the first one.
Yeah. And they recognize, yeah. I hope they capitalize on it now. You know,
while he still has a few years left. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's,
it's that whole layoff thing and not even trying to stay relevant,
but just trying to keep your skills from enrolling.
Like that's a whole thing right there. And then,
and then trying to go perform after that amount of time. Like it's, it's hard.
Yeah. Me and have fallen from that. Yeah. Matt come back to saying, yeah,
he didn't lose a beat. It was crazy. He looked as good as ever.
It was amazing is though he seems to always be working and that's what saved me
when I was off. Like just always like chipping away in the gym, you know,
he's got, you know, him and his brother got,
they got their own schools and they're always in there grappling, working out.
So that's what saved him. Have you take off three years of nothing.
Two years of nothing. A year of nothing.
That's when you come back and you look like a totally different person.
I always point to Mohammad Ali when Muhammad Ali was forced to retire when he
took three years off and then he came back,
he did not look physically like the same guy. You know?
Who did he come back and fight? It wasn't Chuck Wepner.
It was a what the fuck's is zero Foley? No, no, no, no, no. It was um,
fuck the, it's, it's a tragic guy.
A white dude. And then his brother was also like a,
how can I not remember his phone? They're gonna know you talking about man. Um,
on my mama, my mom, Jamie, pull it up. I know you're talking about to a Corey.
Yes. Jerry quarry. Yeah,
Jerry quarry and his brother apparently who only had like one or two pro fights
at all. Also had severe dementia by the time he died. How many fights?
His brother, his brother only had a couple [inaudible] and a couple of profiles.
So there's no Jim Wars if I'm, I think I remember correctly.
But Corey and his,
his dad apparently forced them to have that kind of fight style.
They just went to war all the time. Good bro. And yes,
and during the end of his career, the end of his life I should say.
But that's why I don't, that's why I don't, I don't subscribe.
Like here's the thing, like for me,
this is my view on it is you love combat sports. If you love fighting,
if you love boxing, like you enjoy it all.
Like I love the guy that has to take two to get one.
But I also loved the master and I'll just speak for boxing. The,
the problem that we have is like we've ostracized the,
the master of the game instead of articulating what we're seeing or trying to
articulate what we're saying and leaving that, you know, leaving it right there,
let it be what it is and let the fans decide what they like and don't like.
We tried to tell the fans what they should like, ah, you know,
and this is boring. Oh, hold on.
That's the guy that's going to be speaking properly when all of a sudden done
this guy. Hopefully he is too,
but the likelihood is a lot less because he'd take given two to give one,
but as soon as that guy gets knocked out,
then all of a sudden everybody turns on. Yeah.
So I'm thankful that when I walked into the gym for the first time,
my dad was scouring for a trainer who could teach his son how to hit and not get
hit. He saw verge who became my godfather and has been my trainer, you know,
from my whole career. He said, he said, man, how was it? You know,
I'm a fan of Muhammad Ali. He said, I've had 15 you know,
amateur fights as a heavyweight.
Can you teach my son how to hit and not get hit and viruses.
That's my specialty. But just think of my dad was on something else.
What if my dad was making my son tough? Yeah.
I want him to take it and dish it out. Right.
I may not be sitting before you right now and if you did it,
it would probably be a different kind of conversation. You know,
Virgil Hunter is a special guy. He really is.
You can tell when you hear him talking, you know,
when you hear him talk about the game and the way he would formulate game plans
and strategies, you know, so you know, I remember,
I think it was a Chad Dawson fight.
I think it was that when you knocked out Chad Dawson, when you know,
you could see the look in his face of happiness and accomplishment.
But also we got through the danger. Yeah, we did it. It's over.
But game accomplished. You know, when you, when you had a special relationship,
whether it's an MMA or whether it's unboxing those special relationships between
a trainer and a fighter, they're so valuable. It's, it's,
and to me as a person who loves to watch the sport,
I appreciate them so much because I know that like you could get there on your
own. You know,
you can get there and have like fuse with your trainer and breakup.
You can get like Kovalev love does, you know,
like Cove loves John David Jackson for a while and you know,
now I like that he's with buddy McCart but it's better if you have a real
harmonious relationship with a master. Cause that's what Virgil Hunter is,
is a master. He understands the game. He understands it inside and out. Yeah.
One thing he used to always tell me, and I never looked at it like that,
he was like, son, my, my, my sole purpose,
my main focus is to get you home safe to your family said,
it's not for us to win championships.
It's not for you to be all everything because it gets you home to Tiffany.
And those kids safely. And when he said that,
it just put it all in perspective for me. He's a competitor,
he wants to win but not at the expense of my Hill.
And because he taught me the right way,
we got the winds and the belts and everything anyway,
and then I was also able to go home to my family.
So that's amazing relationship. You know,
one of the things that always stood out to me about you was how composed you are
and you rarely get emotional. You know?
Even like I remember when you fought Carl frosh,
Carr Foche hit you clearly after the bell.
Clearly in a fight you were dominating and you just went like this.
[inaudible] you said you didn't even get mad, you didn't go fuck you,
you did nothing. You took that punch,
you just went turned and just went back to corner. Like it never happened.
Like you just just wiped it clean.
Like that's not going to benefit me to get upset here.
How did you develop that kind of composure?
I think one thing that my dad and verbs did really well from me and my brother
Jonathan who box with me for many years, uh,
they gave us mentor reps like,
like I'd be driving in the car or riding in the car with verge and my dad and
they'd be telling me, listen man, when you get in that ring,
when you spot a Damien listen, that dude tried to hit you low,
you make sure you get your respect.
You don't accept this in the ring. Like this is,
these are things that I was taught. I was like,
I was taught to be a warrior at a young age and oftentimes trainers will train
the body, but they don't train the mind. So plus you and also life experiences,
things that I've been through with my mom and my dad and just,
just all that kind of stuff. Plus my internal makeup, the way, you know,
God made me all of that combined.
I never had to be the loudest talker in the room because I knew that all the,
all the stuff, the real stuff is in me. It's not on me.
So I'm the tight that you hit me like that. I'm going to smile at you.
I got you. We got another round of Pfizer. So my, my,
my anger, my get back.
I'm gonna get it within the confines of these rules,
but you're going to feel me. Kovalev knocked me down. All right bro. I got you.
I smile. You're embarrassed, you're mad, you're frustrated,
you're everything in that eight seconds at eight counts, you're getting,
you feel all every emotion you could possibly feel. But inside I knew,
like now you're gonna have to knock me out because I'm coming to get it.
So some of it is he Nate, some of that was taught.
And then throughout the course of my life and career, I was,
I was given the mentor reps a son. Watch him right here.
Watch how someone so pushed his hand down and he got right back in his face,
not out of the room,
but in the me teaching me and showing me in highlighting what a strong mind was
and what a weak mind was. And typically the weak mind was the loudest talker.
Now, don't get me wrong, I love, I got, I can talk to talking back it up.
It's not a lot of those in the game now MMA or boxing.
So I'm afraid of the guy who's not saying very much the guy that's hard to read.
The guy we were trying to figure out, man, is he what? What's up with him?
That's the guy I'm concerned about the loudest talker.
I used to get excited when guys used to just go over the top. I'd be like, man,
this dude, I gotta keep talking. I got him. Same thing with Coppola.
Fought the first fight. Clothes could've went either way. Uh,
but from the time the first fight ended until the time,
the second second fight started.
I learned more about that guy in that period of time than I did in any around
that I fought him in.
He said so much and I was poking holes in and I was quiet and I was just sitting
back and everybody was misreading the silence. Oh. Or it's scary.
He's not going to check the email. I'm just sitting there like, you know,
taking notes, man. This guy. Keep talking, keep talking.
He was just saying things where I was like, this is a weakness. Now,
if he would've said, look, I felt like I won that fight.
I felt like they robbed me.
I'm coming back to get it and then went silent when dark. Now I'm like, man,
this dude is getting ready. We gotta, we gotta tighten up. Kept talking, man.
Sometimes that talking to reveal a little bit too much about yourself.
What did you see from the talk and just excuse making,
he didn't give me any credit. He started, I mean if it wasn't the written,
I'm exaggerating, but just for the, for the case of emphasis, you know,
if the ring lights weren't too bright, the referee was against them.
If it wasn't the referee, it was the judge is like,
he never owned up to anything that he did wrong.
But if I go back to the research that we did about him before we even fought him
the first time, that line double what we heard. The guy, he doesn't, he doesn't,
he doesn't take ownership of anything. He blames everybody.
Anytime anything goes wrong. He's a front runner. He's a bully. He's this,
he's that. That confirmed everything we had heard. So you're the crusher.
You're Sergei Kovalev. You knocked me down in the second round,
not the 11th the second round you were supposed to finish me, sir.
The fact that we're even talking about a fight being close and the fact that I
finished the fight that's bothering you, that, that, that, that's a,
that that's, that's chipping away at this whole crusher thing that you've been,
that you've been living on. And he couldn't handle it. And instead of owning it,
he blamed John David Jackson. He blamed Ms. Guy. I blame that guy.
That's a sign of weakness, man. Not striking. Mm.
Were you impressed with him getting through the eighth round against yard and
his last fight? I wouldn't say impressed. I mean, listen,
he hasn't gotten where he's gotten by not being tough.
So generally speaking, he's tough. He's a tough individual to a point.
I wasn't surprised. I was just, I was like, dude, if you ever,
if a fighter has ever been saved by the bale, you were just saved by the bail.
Like you were a punch punch or two away from getting, you know,
getting stopped in your home country and in your home, your home city, hometown.
That was the only kind of like jarring part of it. Um,
and in my next door was Kenny recovered.
Is he going to be able to physically recover it then psychologically come back
and try to get back with y'all took from him in that round and he did that.
So he showed me that he's still got something in the tank, but he, he, he's um,
he was the right way to say it. He's fading fast.
Like he's fading right before our eyes. He doesn't have the reaction.
He doesn't have. I still very good and you still,
you still can beat a lot of guys, but he's fading fast.
If there's a Canelo fight on the table,
I think you should take it and ride off in the sunset, man. Go enjoy your life.
Well,
it was interesting how you exposed him in the second fight because the body
shots, the body shots have been a weakness.
Like since then everybody is kind of compromised his body,
they've found what you found out.
Is that something you knew going into the second fight or did you know it in the
first fight? Like when, when do that in the first way?
Did you problem with me in the, in the first fight? Um,
first couple of rounds I was thinking too much and as dude came out fast,
so I'm thinking like I'm trying to get my range and he's like, boom, boom, boom.
And he's, it's not that he's like this crazy power puncher,
it's just that he's sharp and he's accurate. So I'm like catching shots,
I'm getting hit with jabs, I'm trying to figure,
he didn't give me a chance to think and then boom,
I got hit with the right hand and I'm like, I said, bro.
So that was the best thing that could have happened to me. Like I said earlier.
And then you saw the body attack get implemented.
So that was always the game plan.
I won the second fight with everything that I did in the first fight.
Like we unlocked the code in the first fight,
but people couldn't get and knocked down.
They failed to look at the, you know, the next 10 rounds. But yeah,
the next 10 rounds you started to take over and you were solving the riddle.
It's interesting the, the,
the difference in power punchers like there's levels of power punchers yeah,
we always thought of him as this power puncher but cause the crusher knocked a
lot of people out. But then there's like a Julian Jackson dear level,
there's a different, some people just go stiff and George Foreman. Yes.
Like George could kill you. Yes. He hit the Joe Frazier fight like Jesus Christ.
Yes. Terrifying. Yeah. Yeah. George was one of them. I mean there was a,
there's been a bunch of guys like that, but that's that,
that different level of power punching. I mean Ernie shavers was another one.
There was this certain guys, you know, I mean fuck man,
Thomas Hearns in his prime. The way, the way he put away Roberto Duran,
Holy shit. Cue you. And it also the torque,
you know the a there was so much distance between like the, the,
the length of his arms,
the width of his shoulders and then black when that punch would come and cheeses
catch you on the and you got trouble get caught. And that last,
that last power area, yes, yes. It would just put the lights out.
Kurt Coalville have never had that kind of power. It was like a snapping power.
I mean listen he did have power I don't want to take away from no.
Yes he definitely beat a lot of guys in their home towns.
Home countries like an S a reason why like at a certain point in the fight you
would see him hit a guy and then all of a sudden their body language is
different.
And I think one thing that was lost on my whole career that nobody ever talked
about was I probably had one of the best 10
in the sport of boxing over the last, you know, at that time,
10 years like I had beaten the best,
the heaviest punchers in the game and in my weight class. Like,
if you look at Kovalev out of all the damage that he's done in the light
heavyweight division, he had 20 rounds.
He had one moment, he didn't have a wobble,
he didn't have a sh he didn't shake me up anywhere,
be one moment and it was a flash moment. So just quantify that like a guy who,
cause they was the crusher, like he is who he is.
He had one moment in 20 rounds. So a lot of it had to do with my chin.
A lot of it had to do with my toughness, um, which is also underrated and,
and I just like, I know this is going to sound dramatic.
I know it's gonna sound dramatic, but I didn't like to lose.
And for me it was kind of like either win or die. Like that's a fact.
Like that's how I felt. Like it wasn't that serious, but that's how it felt.
Like I always thought about Sunday morning like, dude, if you lose,
it's going to be a crazy ride home on that plane.
Family's going to be looking crazy, feeling bad.
Everybody's going to be looking at you different like,
and you're going to feel crazy.
Like I remember being curled up like in a ball on a Southwest flight coming back
from the next of Kansas. Uh, losing my, the,
the last fight ever lost against John ravish, a guy from Baton Rouge, Louisiana,
14 years old, 14 that is hilarious. 14, 14 years old,
retired, never lost again. And John was,
it was a 14, 15 year old bracket.
So he was a little bit older and he was kind of a stocky kid again,
country strong. And we were watching these other ones separate back.
So you know, it's like a five day tournament,
you could fight four to five times and get to the finals.
And I'm looking at him and I was a little bit intimidating.
He didn't punk me like, Oh, I'm scared to death. But like I was like, man,
I'm a little leery.
And he was knocking guys out and I was decisioning guys along the way.
It could have went either way. I think he wanted a three, two decision,
three judges. One his way too. Judges went my way, but that was I.
But if I was honest with myself,
like I got beat before the fight and at that moment,
like fill in the way I felt coming home, I made up my mind like, dude,
as much as that's up to me, like that's never gonna happen again.
Like I can't control every, every aspect of the fight gang stuff happens.
But it's not going to be because you beat me before the fight.
I can't live with this anymore. So that was my motivation, man,
that just the drive, like it was like win or die. And then,
and then here's the thing about boxing. The only, I don't know about MMA,
but the only sport that I know of where one loss changes your pay scale.
Like if you have a minimum, I, Hey, you went to title,
your first defense is this second defense is that these are your minimums.
We'll negotiate beyond that. You know, whatever, whatever.
Go ahead and lose one that don't get cut in half.
So a lost literally takes food off my family's table.
I also knew that my critics and my supporters, but namely my critics,
they had a front row seat every fight
[inaudible] at the time they're looking down or looking up, looking down,
look and get in a ring. You know,
before the first bill would would ring and I go around and kind of just filled a
ring out and kind of look out and I'd always see them looking,
is tonight gonna be the night? So I had that weigh in on me.
I had the support is that believed in me and was riding for me. And I look,
you know, first couple of rows, my family's right there, my wife,
my kids would always blow her a kiss.
Like all of this stuff was like tangible and real to me and that's the stuff
that would drive me. And so when I get knocked down by a Cova lip,
like that's fight or flight time baby.
Like whatever's in you just going to come out. If you got some turn in you,
that's the time you going to turn.
It's going to be self preservation mode and you're going to be,
so you're going to be more focused on surviving than you are trying to win.
And I think God, man, that, that, that he had his hand on me that night, bro,
and that what was in me was real and it was enough to break him.
And the rest is history, dresses, injury. It isn't,
it is amazing how much energy people get from haters. I mean,
I don't, I don't recommend reading negative comments or negative articles,
but it's amazing how people with a certain kind of resolve a championship
resolve.
We'll take that hater shit and you'll get up 15 minutes earlier than you're
supposed to and you'll have more intensity and you're shadowboxing and you'll,
you'll just push harder. You'll feel it.
But I don't want to give the haters too much credit that it's, well,
it's all you. I don't want to give too much credit. They gave you fuel though.
But it was, it was weird though, and I don't even know how to quantify.
I don't even know how to like explain it, but like early in my career, uh,
they got a lot more credit and you know, I got great mentors,
man. Um, my pastor, Napoleon Kaufman, former Raider, um,
it's a great man of God. Just a great, great man. He would always call him like,
man, pastor man, they're hating on me. And he'd be like, listen son, listen,
stop giving these people all this credit, man. He said, listen man, they got,
they can't do anything to you unless God allows it, man.
Stay focused on what you gotta do.
So I started to get it as I evolved in my pro career and as I started to mature
as a man, so I knew they were there. That element was always going to be there.
But I started letting that element of work for me. Like I wouldn't, like,
I wouldn't just, you know,
just just be enamored with it and I wouldn't just sit there and read comments
and stuff. You know, frankly, the last three or four years of my career,
I didn't read a mention, not one mention on Twitter.
I didn't look at comments on Instagram. Every now and again,
some would slip through,
but I knew they were there and I knew generally what was being said.
I knew generally what the articles in the headline would read. So it was there.
But the real driving force was the people that were riding for me,
fighting for me, supporting me, believing in me.
That element was there and I was going to address that element through my
performance, but they didn't. I don't want to give them too much credit though.
They don't deserve that much because they don't deserve that much credit.
But they're good. That are good to have something there.
But you were very wise in the way you manage.
They're influenced by not reading those comments. Not all the time,
but like I got the revelation, like I said, at a certain point, like, man,
I'm done with this, bro. Not doing this. I only started to read comments again.
Um, frankly,
I didn't watch boxing for the past three or four years of my career really.
And I'm a boxing buff. Why didn't you watch? I was burnt out.
The opinions, the biased, the, the, the double standards,
good stuff to boots. I would just burn.
And it was so weird for me because I'm the guy that would break his neck to go
watch Tuesday night. Gillette fights as a kid. I gotta get back, dude,
you don't even know who's fighting. It doesn't matter.
It's two guys in the ring. I'm watching it Friday night fights for many years.
I was over it going through what I went through with the lawsuit going through
what I went through with the injuries,
the highs and lows and everything in between. I was just burnt out. What,
can you refresh my memory? The loss. It was a promotion lawsuit that lose. Yeah,
yeah, it was, it was, uh, you know, I can't get too much into it,
but it was just something that man, I just, I fought for myself and you know,
but it was, it was a long two year journey. Um,
on my best day, I'm like, you're doing the right thing. So stay, stay,
stay in the race, keep fighting. It may not look it.
It may not be going your way now, but just staying like you're not fighting.
Money's not coming in, but just stay the course. You're doing the right thing.
On my worst day, I'm like, bro, you blowing it. You getting a rust on you.
You know people are writing hot war would rather fight in the courtroom than
fight in the ring. And I'm like, look, that's not, Hey, I'm just trying to,
I'm trying to fight for what I believe is true. So, but, but I grew up a lot.
But coming out of that I was like, man, I'm done with all that stuff man.
Like I don't know how many years I got left in this sport, but I'm,
I'm not focused on y'all. I got to focus on me.
And it wasn't until I retired and got full time in a broadcasting and
commentating that I started to watch again. I started to, you know,
understand who was out there on the, you know,
in the landscape and researching it. But I didn't watch it for many years.
That's crazy. Yeah, I was done. It makes sense.
I mean,
you probably in your early days were so hungry for boxing because you had so
much desire that you wanted to watch it all the time. Excuse me.
But the amount of effort required to become a champion,
that you start to see the behind the scenes though. Hmm.
Then you grow up and you see the business side and you see the dark side.
It's like [inaudible] it's different.
That darkness, dark side. Yeah. There's a lot of that man in boxing. I mean,
it's historical that Don King, Mike Tyson stories, the, I mean,
there's so many stories like the man Don King, Muhammad Ali,
there's so many stories like that. It's, it's so sad.
It's an awful side of the business. Now, when,
what was this before or after the super six tournament? Which one?
That all this was going on with your lawsuits? It was after, shortly after.
So the super six tournament though was where people knew you were an Olympic
gold medalist, but that was where like coming to that,
who was the famous favorite?
Uh, the favorite was just kinda like threefold, but it was Kessler.
Um, Arthur Abraham was dominant at one 60. He had just moved up to 68,
so everybody felt like it was a foregone conclusion.
And he was gonna dominate at the heavier weight class called frosh was the WBC
champion. But he was still kind of like relatively unknown. Like, you know,
he had potential, had a belt, but w you know, he was probably, you know,
I don't know the third favorite. And then you had, uh,
Andre derail.
Obviously you had myself and you had your main Taylor and the Americans,
or at least this is how I viewed it. We were just like,
we were just there to make an interesting, it wasn't about us. It was the,
it was the Europeans party. Um,
and it's funny because almost didn't fight in a tournament.
I was in Mexico on vacation and I'd been hearing about the super six,
but internally, me and my manager, he was like, Dre, I don't,
I don't think his things will come together. These guys are fighting it as,
Hey man, go enjoy your vacation. So I did that. You're right.
I flew in in San Diego,
we drove to Mexico and I ended up getting like a double ear infection. Uh,
I was messed up from the ocean. I probably just something like that. Yeah.
It just kinda came upon me. I don't know. I don't exactly know the origin of it,
so I'm like, I had a little bit of internet access.
I'm looking at something like that. Hey, these guys at wait,
they're doing a kickoff press conference in New York. So I called James.
I'm like, yeah, Jay, what's up? He was like, Hey man,
you need to get there like ASAP, bro. This thing's going down. I'm like, Whoa.
I'm like, you told me it wasn't going to happen. He's like,
I didn't think it was so, but he was also like, you know what though?
If you don't want to go, it's all good. We'll figure it out. So I'm like, man,
I don't want to go with my family. I call verge.
I give him the whole spiel. It's probably like two, three times in my life.
He's had this kind of tone. He was like, listen son, you need to get on a plane.
You're not going to make the New York press conference.
The next stop is Germany are there. Abraham's home country. Get there.
I'm like man, I'm in. You know, I'm with my family. Give him the whole piece.
They get there. So we pack up, we drive two or three hours to San Diego,
get on a fly job. My family back to the Bay area, boom, dropped him off,
get on a flight or red eye that night, double ear infection, wake up in Germany.
And that was my, that was their second stop.
But that was my first stop and that's when I really got the revelation that man
they, this is a joke, like, like this,
they think that me derail and Taylor like we're just gone.
Like that's when I took exception and I was,
when I really kinda like realized that dude like this, this is either,
this is going to be a sink or swim moment for you.
Either you're going to get like, I could've got ruined in a super six.
Like it could've went a whole nother way.
Or what I knew was in me was going to be, you know,
displayed and shown to the world.
And so when you beat Kessler and you won your first title,
that had to be a beautiful moment. I mean, real unreal,
unreal. And it was in my home town, like the same arena,
Oracle arena where the warriors had played for many, many years.
And I'm kind of salty. They're leaving man, chasing Rena. I'm not happy, man.
I'm not happy. Um,
I used to pass by that arena on a highway eight 80 going to King's gym and I
used to look and it'd be, it'd be on the right side and I'd be like,
man of ours, I wonder if I'm a fight. Then one day he said, baby fight.
There you go. Headline. And I was like, really? I'm talking 12, 13 years old.
Wow. I'm like, man, I'm,
I'm a headline and Kessler's arrogance allowed that fight to take place in my
hometown. He had more knockouts than I had. Victories I guys is dope. Like I'm,
I'm not going to beat him. I beat him in his home town. Uh, so we fought there.
Uh, I think it was November 19. And, uh, just unreal man.
And like for a gold medalist, like,
like people don't understand the pressure you have coming into the game. Like,
like everything you do, well, you're expected to do well,
but if there's one slip up now it's like, you know,
everybody comes out the woodworks. Huh? I told you it wasn't going to be that.
So to get the monkey off my back to win my first title was just that pressure,
like that release, the pressure would just immense.
I remember when I was a kid,
when the Olympic team had so many guys that went on to win world champions,
like personnel Whitaker, was it the 76 Olympic team? 84, 84.
Pernell Whitaker, Mark Breland, you know, there was a,
there was so many guys from that era that was Meldrick Taylor,
you know, uh, who else? Who else? Uh, Holyfield Holyfield was there,
but I think Holly forgot does qualify. You got a silver, right?
Something happen when you,
you think about the amount of pressure that mean so many people were looking at
those guys. And I remember when Brenan last tomorrow and Starling,
we got knocked up.
Our mom's tall. I remember so many people were happy.
They were happy that he lost like, ah, another Olympic gold medalists, you know,
he couldn't take him like God. First of all,
God damn Marlon styling was a fucking tail piece.
He was a killer and the super slick. Yup. You know, just a wheel,
seasoned knockout artists in an excellent boxer, you know? I mean, it wasn't,
that's just a great boxer beat another grain boxer.
But there was a weird feeling to it. Like people were happy that Brelyn loss.
I was like, wow, this is, that's crazy. Pressure is different. Yeah,
it's different. Um, and people talk about pressure all the time. Like,
how'd you deal with this? How'd you deal with that? Well,
I credit my faith in God and just, you know,
feeling like there was a purpose for me to be in the game as the foundational
reason. But the,
the practical reason what I've been dealing with pressure since I've been in ma,
you know, since I've been a baby,
like having two parents who were drug addicted, uh,
at a young age and one is a functional addict. Um,
and my dad who raised me as a single parent and then my mother was a full blown
addict for many, many years. She's clean now. She's doing good.
Like that's pressure started there.
Then like coming up throughout the ranks and like dealing with haters and all
this stuff in the gym, in your private gym, well not private gym,
but the gym that you train at and you've got some people that are with you and
this kid is going to be the next and you got some people over in the corner.
Mumbling kid ain't gonna be, y'all ain't gonna be nothing. He's all right.
Like you learn to deal with that stuff,
then they ain't going to the national tournament.
You're dealing with people from all over the U S then you go into the world
tournaments. Like that's pressure. Then you get to a point.
So when I fought a guy like Sergei CoLab, I'd already seen him before.
I'd fought over live 1520 times and mercury already the big, you know,
menacing guy who everybody's afraid of. Like I've fought him before.
I fought him in the Olympics. I fought three Russians in the Olympics.
So it wasn't that odd. I'm guaranteed to win, but I had seen that before.
Even the critics and all the P like we,
I've been dealing with this stuff my whole life and,
and it wasn't anything new. Does, does it feel good? Absolutely not. I mean,
you, you, your hope is that everybody supports you, but you know as,
as successful as this podcast is, you got your bull birds,
you have your critics, birds. I never heard them talk like that. Booboo birds,
you've got people that as soon as you slip up, ah, ah, I knew he was gone.
That's part of the game man. Yeah.
That must have enhanced your relationship with Virgil.
It must've because he believed in you. Yeah, of course.
When you fought for the world title in that very arena where he said you are
going to be headlining when you were like 12, 13 years old,
what the fuck was that like? I must've been amazed. This a real man.
You're just trying to manage your emotions.
Like I remember the night before the fight, uh, I had to, I had my God,
Jack Edward Jackson man who's a great coach, great assistant,
great strength conditioning coach, boxing coach from Houston, Texas.
He'd been with me from day one. Um, I say, man, I gotta get out of the room man.
Like we, we, we, um, drove to trader Joe's just to get some, some, some
cliff bars.
I just needed to clear my head and I remember like talking to my uncle Bob,
who you know, is my dad's best friend who, you know, it wasn't my blood uncle,
but he's basically like an uncle to me. He was boxing fan.
And I remember just like talking to him and him saying, baby,
tomorrow's your day. I'm gonna be, I'm gonna be there front row baby.
Tomorrow is your day. Your dad,
your dad always dreamed about this moment and like just tears running down my
eyes because I was just feeling the pressure. I'm like, dude,
I'm getting ready to fight for a world title at home. Like the pressure,
like you could cut, you can cut it with a knife. Um,
but to be able to bear up under it and, and, and to go get it done bro.
Unreal. Unreal. Could you couldn't, you couldn't script it any better.
Was the second fight with Coalville love your second most satisfying fight?
I like the first one better. The first five better. Really?
Because you managed to survive and come back and then start out pointing.
I just got it a different way. Hmm.
I got it a different way and like it's crazy that you liked that fight better.
Yeah. That's interesting. It's a lot about you. I love the moment with uh,
me and verge in the corner. Um, he showed his worth. I already knew what he had,
but he showed his worth. He said, baby, listen, I leave been knocked down.
SugarRae has been knocked down. They got up now you get up like that.
That's what those are moments you live for.
Like you don't want to be on the cameras,
but if you happen to find yourself there,
you want to know that your team has what it takes and you want to know that you
have would have taken a second round. Bro.
I clawed back 10 rounds against that guy,
the biggest night in my life and then having to deal with everything afterward.
It built me, man, it made me strong like stronger and
that was just that, that, that,
that I won the second fight again with the first fight.
Like I already broke him in the first fight.
Something happened to him like right around a six round.
He was still trying to win to a degree, but I knew physically I was like, man,
I got him. He's not the same.
So of course he's going to whine about the decision because it didn't go his
way. Um, but I beat him in the first fight. We only saw the,
the second fight was the window dressing. We just picked up where we left off.
But everything that that transpired in the second fight really started in the
first fight, the second fight. It's,
it was stunning to me when it seemed like he just quit because it didn't seem
like it. D I mean it almost seemed like a premature stoppage,
but then you realize that he didn't want to fight any longer. Yeah.
Tony weeks did a great job. He saved Coke. I mean, you know, and in hindsight,
you know, you wish you would have landed the one shot and he went, you know,
you got knocked out and it was clear. But listen, man, um,
I'll all the excuses and stuff like I was thinking about this the other day,
every big win that I've had, there was an excuse attached to it.
So you go back to Kessler. Oh, he headbutted me. He's fighting dirty. No,
I'm fighting in a style that you don't know how to deal with.
You look at call frosh. It was boring.
Why didn't you make it more interesting? You look at Chad Dawson. Oh,
he was waiting [inaudible] Chad Dawson called me out.
I was at home minding my own business and he said, I want to fight Andre ward.
I'll come down to his weight and I'll fight him in Oakland. You look at Kessler,
I mean you look at Coalville lip first fight. I got Rob second fight.
They cheated me. Come on y'all.
Every big win that Andre ward has cannot have an asterick next to it.
Like so either either.
I'm not the guy that my record says that I am or somebody is not being honest
over here. You see what I'm saying?
But don't you think that's inherent with boxing when there's certain people that
don't ever want to accept defeat no matter what and when there's a situation
where there's a possible reason why they lost,
that didn't sort of fit into the rule books. Like he hit me low or they stopped.
It's too soon. Or the Kovalev fight.
You know like the second fight in particular, like the first fight.
Maybe he could make an argument that he thinks he should've won a decision,
but the second fight, I mean he wasn't,
he wasn't jumping up looking to beat that eight count,
dust his gloves off and get back at it.
He was basically surrendering. He was done man.
Those body shots with everything,
people forget about the right hand that started all the trouble where he did the
funny dance and then like the, the, the 15 unanswered shots after that. Yeah.
Um, and I'll probably sound of the body shots that landed maybe one straight,
a little low. But again, bro, your name is the crusher. Like,
like why like if you hit me low, like,
and I tried to be as fair as I possibly can. I'm coming to get that back bro.
Like if it's, if I feel like it's intentional, like this accident, you know,
I was all good, you know it happened. But if you're trying to like, like,
like dethrone me or beat me from, from a foul, like I'm coming to get that back.
Why all of a sudden, like all the people that said that, that, that, you know,
you're not going to beat Kovalev you, you know,
look what he did to this guy's gonna do the same thing to you. You're too small.
Those are the same people coming to the rescue of a guy whose nickname is a
crusher and who's missing and all this stuff I've been saying, you know, like,
like he should be able to defend himself.
He should be able to get me off of him.
A little guy that just moved up from one 68 little old me
was the thing about Cove live too. Like he killed a guy early in his career,
right? Yeah. And that was something that, you know,
that there's a feeling when a car has done that is there's a fear to facing that
guy. And I had to face that fear. I had to face that fear. I'm human. Um,
so that was presented to me, but that's where the mindset comes into play.
That's where my faith comes into play where I'm like, listen man,
unfortunately that happened to that guy, but you ain't doing it to me.
Like that's the mindset part.
Like if you allow that stuff to see Penn take root and start to fester in your
heart, in your mind, you'll never, you'll never get it.
Get past fit the starting line. You'll go out there and be like, man,
who was that dude that was performing that night? That wasn't me. Um,
he was going to have to do something to me cause cause I was coming to whim.
And again, it's not that I'm just, I'm not the toughest guy
in the world, but like I just believed what I believed.
I felt like I was there for a reason and unfortunately that happened to that
young man, but I just didn't believe that was gonna happen to me.
And that's what I had to keep feeding myself in order to get past that and then
go perform. Now how did you make the decision? You stop him in the second fight.
How did you make the decision that that's it?
It was almost it for me after the first fight. Really? Yeah.
That's the closest I've ever, I've talked retirement in the past, uh,
like internally with my wife and stuff. Um,
but after the first fight, I don't know if it was, uh, I think it was physical,
like all of the surgeries and rehab and just the years.
How many different surgeries? Joe? About three. Which all in the shoulder?
I'm not shoulders. Knee. Yeah. Yeah man. That's kiss or something. Yeah.
At one ACO woman discuss. Yeah. Um,
I think it was the physical part. I think it was just the,
the toll of the sport and then may,
may maybe some of the reaction like, like, you know,
for a split second I'm like, here we go again. Like, like it's always something,
you know, I beat the guy that you guys say, I couldn't be Matt now.
Now you know, people feel like I got robbed.
Like that's a fight that could have went either way, you know, by pointed to,
you can't, you can't have a polarizing opinion about, you may say, man,
I thought Wardlaw I can live with that. But all the Rob stuff like,
so I think it was a combination of just everything. I was like, man,
I'm done man. Like I'm not doing this no more.
I didn't do anything for three months after that fight.
And I remember going to speak to my pastor about it because he did the same
thing. Like he, you know, he was all,
everything at U dub play six years in the league and all of a sudden, boom,
one day he was like, I'm done. And never looked back.
So I went and sat with them and I was like, man, passion man. I don't know man.
I think I'm done. And he's just listening. Look very wise man. And um,
so I'm giving them the whole spiel. I'm like, man,
I haven't done it in three months. I've never done that. That's gotta be a sign.
I'm done. He said, you know what son? He said, I think, uh, he's,
I think you'll be fine if you, if you retire. He said,
but I think you got one more left in you. I remember just,
I thought he was going to side with me. I thought it would be like, yeah, sign,
that's it. And I was a little disappointed, honestly. I was like,
really? I was like, yeah, but I told you I hadn't done anything in three months.
He was like, Oh no, no, no. He said, once you get going,
you know the fire will be rekindled. Wow.
So I took him at his word and I started to kind of get back going,
moving my body, and then that happened. I started to get that fire back. And uh,
once we got the money right, I was like, I'm gonna do it again. Boom.
Won the fight. And I didn't know for sure, but I was kinda feeling like,
okay, well, you know, I felt like that after the first one,
this may be it after the second one, but then the opportunity started coming.
HBO had a three-five deal on the table and basically it was going to be a gimme
fight in Oakland at home. Kind of a celebration.
I moved to cruise away against Tony bell. You probably in the UK.
Did you want to move to cruiserweight? Yay.
There was nothing else at light heavyweight.
What about a rubber match that wasn't exciting for, you know, beat him twice.
It Kovalev have for a rubber man. No, no, really. I mean he will probably put,
if somebody asked him like, you want to reimagine? Well yes,
of course he didn't want it. He didn't really want it.
So that was the three fight exit strategy with HBO gimme fight ally heavy or
puck onto a catch weight at home away when they walk around the back then, yeah,
about 85 so you would have had a gain weight out.
I had to tighten myself up at 85 90 you're probably low weight. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's crazy. Weight limit is 90 it's 200 it's 200 yeah, I probably would.
I probably wouldn't got to two though.
High would have been on one 91 92 something like that.
So that was a three five deal and then 35 was going to be Anthony Joshua.
I don't know if he would have been made. We hadn't even gotten that far,
but that was our plan. Jesus Christ. Right.
How much would you have gained to get up to heavyweight? Maybe two.
That's it. Maybe too. I can't, I'm never going to be as big as you guys,
so why would I weigh myself down? Right. Yeah. Very dangerous situation,
you know? Uh,
but that was something we were talking about and verge mentioned it in the
post-fight press conference with Kovalev. That guy's fucking gigantic,
but we hadn't been, him being vert hadn't talked about like we talked about it,
but we didn't say we were gonna mention anything publicly. Oh.
And then he came out with, I'm sitting there chilling out, just one of my,
he's like, yeah, you only want Anthony Joshua like chill, bro.
Like he's so much bigger than you. Yeah. It's all good though.
That guy's gigantic. I've been fighting big guys my whole life.
I'm sure you have. So the three fight deal was on the table
and Roman Gonzalez [inaudible] or [inaudible] coy,
[inaudible] Chi, sobering VSI side.
We're getting ready to fight their rematch at the home Depot center.
I think it was September 9th, September 6th. That was a Wednesday.
I was supposed to be in LA to announce the new signing and get ready to call
that fight that Wednesday I come home and I'm kinda like, I'm,
I'm not Bullhorn, but I'm in tears. And I told my wife, I was like,
I don't want to do it anymore. And even saying that sounded crazy to me.
She was like, she was just real quiet. I'm thinking like,
why is he not saying nothing? I'm like, I don't think I want to do this anymore.
And she said something she had never said previously. Typically she's like,
Bay loo. It's not time. Come on, you gotta get up. I know you feel this way.
I know you're by, but come on. I feel like you still got time in the sport.
First time she ever agreed with me, she was like,
I think the decision has already made, right. I was like, what
should I think the decision has already made? She said,
I've been looking at you throughout this whole day and some of the stuff you've
been saying, and I've never really seen you like this. She said,
I think it's already made. I took that out, bro. Started making phone calls,
call, call my lawyer who was, you know, one of my good friends, Josh Dubin,
said, Hey bro, I think that may be it for me. And he had been wanting me to be,
you know, done. He was like, if you feel that way, bro, I'm gonna support you.
Call my manager the next morning. And it took us. So I went, I went,
I went that weekend and call the fight.
We held off on the announcement and my lawyer just told HBO like, look,
he's going through some things. We're good. Give us a couple of days.
So I got through that weekend and he said, do you still feel like that?
Come Monday one. I was like, bro, I think I'm done. Long story short, uh,
we ended up announcing it September 21st, so it was like a two week period.
We are trying to keep it under wraps,
but I was undoing all the stuff I was letting the necessary people know.
Rock nation, HBO, everybody know. And, um, the night before I announced it, man,
me and my good friend, um, who is a director, he's also directing my doc, uh,
Deontay Thompson. He, um, we put together this video,
it was like a legacy video where I had my young son,
my middle son and my oldest son. And those are like, those are like, you know,
that was me at that point in time in my career and we did this whole video that
I was going to announce my retirement with and um,
and actually have the doc that I'm working on right now is about this.
Like why did the best fighter in the world of the world at that time walk away
from the sport on top shot that video man, the day of my retirement, bro.
And the response was just overwhelming. You know, it was overwhelming.
Like I just couldn't believe the amount of people that were reaching out. And,
and it was, it was, it was like good and bad.
Like it was good cause I was getting support, but it felt like somebody died.
Like I felt like I died, bro. I'm looking at, he's arrest in Pete,
like not literal rest in pieces, but like the comments were like Arestin peace,
like, bro, are you? So I couldn't be like, man, I'm like ward, not you man.
Oh my God, man. And it was just,
it was like just this huge reaction and it was overwhelming.
Um, and in the two years that followed,
like I said at the beginning of this podcast,
harder than I thought it was going to be one of the hardest,
if not the hardest thing I've ever tried, had to do.
And still like I still have to do, like it's a daily decision and be like,
I'm not doing it no more.
But one of the most rewarding man and it was a necessary evil.
And I hope that one day, man, the young guys can look up one day and say, man,
I'm gonna do the Andre ward. I'm done. I'm out. Like,
how long do we have to do it before we feel satisfied? Look, bro,
save your money if you don't, if you're not financially literate,
go get some help. Um, ask questions.
And as soon as you feel like you're not really there,
you don't want to do it no more.
I don't have no son. I said, bro, there's other stuff you can do.
Hope to be an example in that area. Well,
it's so important I think for there to be a guy like you because people always
have this narrative. Fighters always come back.
They always fight like sugar Ray Leonard did when he fought, you know,
later in his career when he fought Zani Leilani,
but then he went and fought. Yeah, the Terry Norris fight was hard to watch,
man. And then, you know, Hector Camacho stopped.
I mean it was like it got Camacho couldn't punch either.
It was in his calf was all fucked up back then and Billy blanks were training
them. You remember that? Yup. I mean,
is this sad when you see these guys to still try to do it over and over and over
again until the same story keeps repeating itself? When a guy like you,
the,
it was only Hagler before you Hagler was only the only guy living his lowest
too. Oh, that's true. Lennox Lewis, a handful. Yes, a handful. Yeah.
Lenox Hill was a brilliant guy too. You know, it's like plays chess.
He's articulate. He's like, he's an interesting,
intelligent guy that just say, nah, we're good.
As we did everything we need to do. We did everything we needed to do.
The the having those guys like you is so important for young fighters because
they get told by the, by the assholes, you know, Hey, you know,
all fighters is gonna wind up with brain damage.
All fighters is gonna wind up going out on their back.
They're all gonna wind up coming back after their prime.
It's so important for guys like you to say, you know,
know that you can manage it correctly. These are shark infested waters,
but if you stay on the rocks and you do your due diligence and you put in the
work and your discipline and you fight correctly,
I agree with you so wholeheartedly about appreciation of the masters of a real
masterful boxer. Like when I always talk to people, Buffalo may,
whether they talk all this shit, he does this, he does that.
He's got all this money. I go save all that. Forget about us talking.
Watch how that guy fights. He fucking barely gets hit.
He's been rocked maybe twice in his whole career.
My Donna and I'm Shane and sugar Shane Mosley. Those are the only two,
the only two guys that cracked him and he wound up winning both those fights.
He's a master masterful boxer and that's what everybody should emulate this
they, I mean,
I loved the Arturo Gotti making sure fights as much as anybody did,
but if that was my son, I'd be freaking the fuck out. I'd be like,
don't fight like that. It's not worth it.
I don't give a fuck how many of these drunk and assholes cheer you on.
They're not going to be with you when you wake up in the morning.
Your head is pounding in your head when you have a hard time looking at light,
when you have to have all the shades closed,
when the the just a little crack of light coming into the shade is hurting you.
It's giving you a headache now.
They're not going to be there with you when you're old.
[inaudible] just always put it like this and that's the shed a lot of people
down. He said, man, let me ask you a question.
He'd do this to reel to report it and stuff like on a,
like if there was an open workout and he knew it was a particular reporter in
there that was, you know, around, you know, talking down against, you know,
guys who go by, he was an actual question. You got kids. Oh yeah, you got a son.
Absolutely. If you want to just send a box.
And it was two guys at the gym and one coach said, amen.
I'm a teach us how not to hit and I get here, period. I know this art,
I've mastered it and I'm going to help him master it.
And then you got this guy over here to see, look man, I'm a, um,
he may have to take two to give one, but look, he's going to be tough.
He's going to be durable. And who would you send your kid with? And they go, ah,
the first guy. Well there you have it. Well,
I think there's a false narrative too.
Here's the false narrative is that the guy who takes two to give one is tougher.
I think that's nonsense.
I think the guy who hits and doesn't get hit can be just as tough if not tougher
cause it's hard. It's not talked about. Right. It's a false narrative.
To your point. Yes. Like my lazy days in the gym would be, man,
I'm just going to fight today bro.
I'm gonna stand toe to toe and just get it in. I'm tired physically.
I'm not trying to, you know, execute this game plan and day.
I'm just going to try to keep a tight defense. You just go to war. Those are my,
those are my, like my lazy days that when you gotta like,
like embody a game plan and then round after round,
even when things aren't going your way, try to stick to that game plan, bro.
That's hard. Yeah. That, that, that's draining. Right. Um,
and this is something again that I've never said cause I don't, I'm not,
I don't like talking about myself, man. I try to stay out the way and, but bro,
I was one of the toughest fighters in the sport of boxing for the past 10 years
when I was active. Period. No, no question about it.
It's just not talked about the chains and not talked about, you know,
the toughness part because it's not really associated with the guy who can,
you know, do it a certain way.
But if you really think about my big fight in the end,
the big guys that could punch like I didn't beat them by moving away.
I beat them by being in the wheelhouse period. And even Floyd,
like people don't realize like we will highlight like visible times that we saw
Floyd get hit, man, you're getting buzzed and all kinds of stuff is going on.
People don't even know. Right. But we're chameleons as fighters.
We have to be because if we show weakness,
now's water is water and shark infested water.
I mean his blood and shark infested water. Sure. Even in the economy,
McGregor fight, he got clipped with a big left up or cut man.
You get bud being and you just tighten down and people thought, God,
I wasn't a hard shot. Yes it was. You didn't know it. No float.
Floyd Floyd has had to deal with that throughout the course of his careers.
Many times that we didn't know. I like how Floyd changed his style too.
He would the pretty boy, pretty boy Floyd style early in his career.
I mean he was much more knockout oriented.
He was much more aggressive but he would get hit more than to it and he also
broke his hand a bunch of times, you know,
and he just developed a smarter style.
But people don't remember those knockouts like when he just see that fight with
that Japanese dude.
I had so many fucking arguments about that five same where they were trying to
say that that was a fixed fight. I'm like, God dammit. Listen to me.
That dude is 126 pounds. Yup.
He had no fucking business being in there with Floyd Mayweather ever,
ever forget about Conor McGregor. Conor McGregor is a big man. Yup.
That's a tiny dude. That dude is 126 pound fighter.
He's fighting Floyd Mayweather who's arguably the best boxer of all time and
Florida doesn't even have to fucking train for that guy.
He came in there with a little bit of a belly and he's just moving his arms
round like this, smiling at him. Hey man,
you fucked your never seen flow look like that before man.
But he want easy and people were saying, Oh look how the guy went down.
That's how it happens when a big man who's real natural welterweight hits 126
pound fighter. That's what the fuck happens. Slow was, I heard him too.
He was trying to hurt him. It's almost like fluid.
I don't know what the agreement was but it was almost like, yeah exhibition.
Wait. Yeah and Floyd's a competitor like like,
like unapologetically he's coming to win every time he,
you could tell flow with opening up flows. Truck flow was trying to hurt him.
Do you think he's going to go about it again?
Cause there's talk of other fighters. There's talk of,
I mean he goes through money like water and he's got a fuck load of it,
but God damn, he loves to spend it.
And he's had some financial troubles in the past because of his flashy
lifestyle.
But his skill and his overall boxing ability and his ability to talk shit and
generate interest have pulled him out of these problems. I hope not
50 now, 50 times 50 fights. Pretty amazed. The training camp, I said no.
Pretty amazing. If he does, if he does stop, pretty amazing. That's enough.
Yeah. He's,
he's retired on what three different occasions came back benefited from it?
I think he's good. Selfishly I would love to see it but,
but realistically I think, I think he's good.
The only thing I could think would maybe talk him out of it is if there was
something that could generate a massive amount of money, like a pack-out fight,
like a PAC. I'll fight, you know, pack y'all still.
I mean after he beat Keith Thurman, like, Ooh,
well what's a massive amount of money? I don't know.
Cause he's had a massive amount. I know I comp team time.
I would like to ask him like legitimately, Hey man, how much you got left?
I think he would do it for a B. There was a B behind it or like, like,
like a strong like 750 million upside.
Like Floyd ain't it down a B. Is that possible?
Can you get $1 billion? Why not? Right.
If anybody could do it right now it's Floyd. I mean who would he fight?
I feel like floated out to fight a young guy. Like he would have to be like,
like he's, he's, he's, he's done the kind of McGregor thing. People are like,
Oh you got us. Like he'd have to fight a real threat. Like dude,
cause people, people are pay that kind of money to see that,
that OGO so like who like Terrence would have to be at, I don't know.
But again, I don't know commercially if it's Terrance big enough, I'm not sure.
But it would have to be one of those kinda guys. Arrow,
you know Terrance before people would say job, I don't care.
Pay-per-view is 200 I don't care. Like,
I don't think there's any star on that level right now. Right.
I don't think there's any star on the level of where Floyd was when he was
younger in his prom. Yeah.
There's no one who generates that amount of eyes. Okay.
Nello fight could do something like that. It could but can.
I was talking about fighting Colette Lev. Right, but he would, he would,
he would stop talking about finding Kobalanski running marathons.
If flow was coming back it would be in a couple of who have a Floyd would make
him drop down like 145 pounds or something crazy as he should.
What did he make them fight at the first time? One 52 or something like that.
He came with some arbitrary number. Low bit. It was below junior middle weight.
I think it was like 50 to Oscar de LA Jolla did it to float when they fought.
Yeah, because he was the ASI. Yeah. He picked the gloves, right? Del Rayez.
He picked the size of the ring. He picked everything. You got to,
you're in the driver's seat. Yes.
So don't get mad cause Floyd is doing it right now. Right. Canelo great fighter.
He's the a side the majority of the time, unless you're fighting me.
So look right. If you want this money, this is what we're going to do, isn't it?
Right now the a plus in the a side though,
it seems like Canelo's so huge. Particularly the Mexican medium.
They will fight again. Yes. If they fought right now Floyd's still the a plus.
But Canelo is kind of a, or at least to a minus maybe to everybody.
But he'll always be,
Floyd will always be the bigger star just based on what he's amassed in his
career and just who you use. But when you look at what Canelo does,
like when he knocked out Amir Khan, he's at, you know, he,
that motherfucker could put some heat on some punches. You can punch shit.
He can punish box. You could box too. Do you think he very,
that's one thing he really did learn from fighting Florida.
You know how to not be there. You know?
And you saw that in the subsequent fights, like he learned from that fight.
Like that was a learning lesson and you could see in that fight him like,
like realizing as a fight was going on, like, no, fuck,
I'm on another level of this video game and I don't know how to beat this boss.
Like Floyd was just shutting them down and just doing beautiful things for
levels to the game from people appreciate boxing.
That's one of the best fights to watch cause you've got this murderous young
upstart who's a devastating puncher,
was a big strong kid who's just tough as fuck.
He just embraces that Mexican style of fighting pressure.
A lot of power moving forward. That's exciting to me, man. Yeah. Like pee pee.
I don't, I get it. But like on the other hand, I don't get it.
Like how do you not see what's happening right now?
You have a young dude who can really punch, like we just said,
one punch can change it. All employees a little bit older. He's not old,
but he's older. Yeah. And he found a way to neutralize this young bull,
this young lion, and then expose him like he took away his strength and then,
you know, exposed his weakness like tight, like in a 12 round fashion. Yeah.
Like not one round, not five,
not 10 but 12 rounds and left and left Canelo without answers.
Like that type of stuff. That's the way I was brought up. Yeah. Like man,
take away his greatest strength and, and, and, and exposes weakness, bro. Like,
like that to me, I'm, I can watch 20 rounds like that.
I think that's because you are,
you're not just a great fighter, but you're also,
you're a deep fan of the sport. I mean, but it wasn't always like that.
But when you were a kid, were you a big fan of it? Yeah, of course.
So you understand like the, the,
when you're seeing a masterful performance, you understand that the,
the general public really doesn't understand what's happening.
They don't see it.
And that's our job as analysts and writers to educate the people.
You're gonna have your dye hearts,
they're going to pick and choose what they like. And generally speaking,
the die hard is gonna you know, appreciate both styles.
They maybe have a favorite style but they're going to an end for all of them.
Yeah. It's the fight is over the casual, right. And we in boxing we kill our,
so we shoot ourselves in the foot because a,
there's so much in fighting and then you have people literally like when a guy's
fighting a masters fight and Aw man, it's not worth you.
It's not worth watching. I'll you an example, I'll bring it to the MMA world.
I'm a casual MMA fan. Like Gilbert Melendez. We've,
I've worked out with him, Nick and Nate. Um, and a couple other guys like,
so I'll watch if one of those guys a final, you know,
some of those guys don't fight anymore, but like,
or core me a or maybe a challenge. Joan was like,
I'll watch those types of guys. I've never heard, maybe you can inline,
but I've never heard an announcer like rip a guy.
Like even if a guy has no ground game, he's like, look,
if so and so gets him on the ground, he's in trouble.
But if you stand up with this guy, you're giving me a reason to stay engaged.
We inboxing a lot of times. Um, and we have in past times,
I think we've gotten a little bit better as of late. Ah know this is terrible.
Listen man, if I'm a casual fan, why am I going to stick around?
The fight is over the casual and not the hardcore fan. So we make, you know,
a guy who can hit and not get hit. Like it's some, you know,
some super S like this is some special thing that you know, you know,
you gotta be really, really smart to understand. It's really not.
It's the fundamentals of the game.
Like when you go into a gym for the first time, Hey man, you, your J, Hey man,
you hit this guy, take a half step back so we can return fire.
It's the fundamentals of the game at the highest level. It's not that deep.
It's really not. It's being presented to people like as deep. It's not,
it's hit and not get hit. And even in the whole hitting, I get hit concept,
you're going to get hit, you're going to get hit,
you can't avoid contact all the time. And then you got to be able to see, okay,
this dude,
he really doesn't like to get up and may he just got hit with that good shot
man. He came back and many, many responded. Wow man, that dude does have heart.
If you're really looking at him, you're going to see a fight.
You're gonna see boxing all in one fight. Even against the guy who was a master.
You're gonna see the whole gamut. Well,
in sports commentary there is a way that sports people, right?
And there's a way that sports people do commentary where it's very negative and
they like to call people. They like to call people bombs. They like,
there's an appeal to a certain kind of fan and it's very profitable to be very
negative and to to to him to talk about a certain way.
I made a very conscious decision when I started doing commentary to celebrate
these fighters and to try to honor their hard work and what they're doing.
And to let people know how spectacular it is to me,
someone who loves the sport and I stay away from negative as much as possible
unless it's absolutely negative to talk about to show like maybe if someone
would have to make some egregious error for me, for me to say,
don't ever do this. When I talk about these guys,
I want people to feel how I feel when I watch.
If I watch like Demetrius mighty mouse Johnson was like one of my favorite of
all time and one of the thing about Demetrius to me that's so spectacular was
that he was able to fight these amazing fighters and make them look like they
had no business being in there with him, his movement, his arsenal,
his technique, he could do anything. He could take you down, he could submit,
you could kick you, he could punch you. He moved his footwork, his movement.
It was a masterful, but he had a hard time finding an audience. I did my best.
I did my best to let people know like you are watching a special person.
You are watching a magician in here. I mean, he's,
he's on the highest level I've ever seen in all my years of watching combat
sports. That's as high as it ever gets. Yeah.
He's just 125 pounds and someone could get excited about it, but you,
you did your part and try it. You did your part. Um, and listen,
there's times you gotta call fighters out for stuff. I'm not, I'm not opposed.
And I'm not saying that you always have to be in alignment with a fighter.
You know, if his, if his justified to call him out, if he, if he, if he,
if he put on a bad performance, look bro,
he didn't perform the way Timothy Bradley did that recently.
And I think it was very justified. Which one was a,
there was a Russian heavyweight and a,
he was on an undercard and he was fighting this other dude.
And the dude kinda laid down. And Timothy Bradley was like, listen,
let's be honest, that mom support. He felt like he wanted a way out.
He wasn't really here to fight. He was here to Pat this guy's record. I'm like,
man, you know, that's, that's exactly true. Yeah.
You got to remain credible to yes. You know. [inaudible] incredible.
That's one of the things that's important about you.
Like you are very credible and, but also very positive and fair.
You're fair. Praise. I try to be, man. I like, I think also what's,
what's hurt like, uh, and I think we do a great job, uh, at ESPN will not Cruz,
you know what? You guys have replaced the best, which used to be HBS.
When HBO went away, man, I was like,
I can't believe they're getting out of the boxing game. I couldn't believe.
I'm still shocked. I can't, there was a foot with 40 years or something.
I grew up from dozy duh, duh, duh, duh. Look, I grew up on, yeah,
I'll get it on my DVR every time. Like, here we go. Who's fighting?
That's one thing that we try to stress. You know, our, our, our lead producer,
Mike McQuade, uh, Joe Teza toward Tim Braley, Mark Kriegel, Bernardo as sooner,
Christina poncho, like we are trying to be fair and objective,
but yet truthful. And if you and we,
everybody has a reference for the guys that are getting in there and with all of
that on the table,
then we tried to call it from that point what's happening in or what's happening
in past times and even a little bit still today is personal agendas,
personal issues like spill over into the commentary or in to the article that's
being written. Like if you don't like Floyd's lifestyle,
I don't ascribe to Floyd's lifestyle, but that's not my business as a fighter.
We're going to call this the way we see it. Yes,
he is arguably one of the greatest of all time. Now,
wherever you have on that list, that's your decision. Subjective.
But people would take the lifestyle and things that was [inaudible]. He'll flip.
No man, you're, you're letting that spill over into this and that.
Now you're messing up this broadcast right now because Floyd's doing something
and we're not acknowledging it and it's clear that you don't like him.
That's the issue. Keep those things separate lifestyles, lifestyle.
You're gonna talk about that and you're doing a background story, whatever.
Okay, address that. But if we're talking in the ring, come on man. Genius. Well,
it's so interesting too,
to see a guy like you who is a former two division world champion and an Olympic
gold medalist who also transitions to be an excellent broadcaster because
there's only been a few George Foreman. I love him to death, but he was odd.
Big Joe was doing commentary, but he would say crazy shit.
Yeah. You'd be like, what does he say? I may spoke his mind.
I think that's why people loved him yet. So folksy. Yeah, it was such a a,
you know, I mean, and you knew, I mean,
he's obviously a fantastic heavyweight and then the oldest heavy,
the oldest guy ever to win the heavyweight title. Yeah. Roy was great as,
as a commentator as well, you know, but where the fuck is Jim Lampley?
I'm not sure what Jim's doing right now. You know,
I'm surprised he's not out there too. I actually owe Jim a call. Um,
I don't know. I don't understand that. He was so good. He is to me,
the gold standard of play by play that got him could do whatever he wants.
I did hear that he was teaching somewhere, you know,
that's one thing he's doing about teaching. Teaching.
You had a college somewhere. Really? Yeah. Wow. What's he teaching?
I'm not sure. I'm sure. I'm sure. Wow. How interesting.
Jim could do whatever he wants. A dad who's intelligent, he's smart.
He's paid his dues, I think. I think he's going to have his pick.
I'm not sure why we haven't seen him out there in the forefront,
but I'm sure he's doing something. Yeah, I miss him. Yeah, me too man.
Like that's one of my mentors.
Like I started off without burns thing is show time.
That was one of my first mentors. Um,
then obviously Lampley Kellerman where's Kellerman?
Cause Kellerman's doing other things for ESPN, but he's not calling fight.
He works with us. Does he? But he's, he doesn't do every fight.
He'll do specific fights. He'll be at the desk.
So he's not [inaudible] he's not going side. But what is that?
Why isn't he doing recess shoe or man, he's got a lot going on. What the fuck?
He's got a lot going on. But we have a, we have a great crew man.
Have a great week. Joe. Tessa toy man. Come on. Legend in the game. Yes.
Legend in the game and you and Tim together. A fantastic combination. You know,
it's amazing man. We got our guy Mark Kriegel you know doin during the,
you know,
personal stories and getting guys back around like probably the best storyteller
that I know that's out right now. Well it's so interesting,
this ESPN plus thing and the zone and these streaming services that have come
along that have sort of changed. Everything changed.
I mean I don't worry about taping anything anymore.
I know I'm going to go home and I'm either going to watch like I watch them on
my phone if I'm out,
like I was at dinner with my wife and I was sneaking fights in the bathroom.
Am I sure I have to take a leak or see what the fuck is going on?
Have watching fights while I'm peeing.
It's like you can get it anywhere as long as you have internet service now,
you know, I mean it's, that's so fantastic. That's where we're headed.
My like exclusively. Yeah, I think so too.
I mean UFC thinks so as well and they made this deal with ESPN and a lot of
people freaked out. But for me it's fucking great. I, I mean it's great.
You know, my daughter had this, uh, event that she was going to and uh,
you know, as soon as it was over, I ran upstairs and I pull out the phone.
I'm watching fights. I mean it's just crazy. It's crazy. Instantaneously.
You don't have to go home. You get them right there, you know?
It's just a whole new world, this world of I want it right now. You know,
it was funny though, cause I hear people with the, you know,
that I have the old narrative of boxing. You still don't listen. The, the,
the reports of boxing's demise has been greatly exaggerated.
I've been hearing this stuff for so long, like boxing,
like it's just like for casual fans or just something cool to say like, no,
or why? Why isn't boxing what it used to be listened to? Arrows are there areas,
but in times of like available content, available fights,
like I think we're at an all time high, right? Yes, I think so too.
There are other people doing what they're doing. God bless them.
But what we're doing at ESPN, man, I think it's unmatched. Yeah.
I think ESPN is fantastic right now and I appreciate the zone as well. I mean,
boxing is an amazing place right now.
There's so many elite fighters and there's a lot of hype on the sport right now.
There's people that are very excited about it. People that are casual fans.
Look that Tyson Feuer Deontay Wilder fight did more for heavyweight boxing than
I think any fight in recent memory.
When Deontay knocked him down the 12th round and Tyson fury Rose like Lazarus
and you're like, Holy shit, this fight still going on.
He did and then after that he won the round. They're like, this is insane.
He looks like he's getting, it looked like his soul left his fucking body.
I turned on my wife. I was like, Oh, that's a rat turned back. I was like, what?
He got up within the tink out like I'm trying to figure out if it was over and
they were, they just had to, one dude got up and when the rest of the round,
dude, I was watching in my bed, right. So I'm, I'm S, I'm leaning back,
my feet are on the bed. Deontay hits him.
I rock it towards the front of the bed. I'm sitting down. I'm like, Holy shit.
He knocked him out in the 12th round. He got up,
he got up and I'm sitting there. Oh my God. Oh my God.
My wife comes in the room. She's like, what the fuck are you doing? I'm like,
he got up. He got up. She just walks way with her hands up.
If he really saved his career, he did. He put tens of millions of that,
that that was the the a hundred million dollar up.
It was the greatest getup of all time.
I don't know how much you got from ESPN is reported 100 million.
Some people say no, but that get up was, was, was a very, very wealthy get up.
And then how about the fact that he gives his entire purse away and charity?
I mean, who the fuck gives $10 million away to charity? I love to give,
but I ain't given a whole way. No way. After that fight, keep half.
I'm doing, I got something for you. But on the million,
everybody was still love you. I can't do that. Not the whole thing.
He's an interesting cat man.
And the the will to get up mean Deontay Wilder is a terrifying puncher.
He's a terrifying puncher. But it's like I said earlier,
they're those intangibles. They're in you, not on you. Yeah.
And he showed what was in him in that moment. Oh, it's 100% in him. You,
there's not a goddamn person in the world that can count out Tyson fury after
that. I mean, that man is special. The way he Rose.
I can't wait to see the rain man. Woo. Is that gonna happen? It's gonna happen.
There's all this talk, but [inaudible] reportedly not official,
but reportedly February Las Vegas, but doesn't he have to?
Tyson has to get past, what was his name? Otto wiling. Valine. Valine.
Marlene. He's got to get past that dude. That might not happen.
I mean he could lose to that guy. All weird shit happens. Sort T's. Yes.
He's dangerous fight. Put it on him in that first fight,
but you'll lose our tease at least 150 years old at least. Right. At least.
At least on the Cuban birth certificates. He's been like 40 for like 10 years.
Like bro, come on. You, you keep saying you 40 years or you're,
you're older than that, right? No, no.
He's been telling us that he's been the same age for a long time. Um,
I'm hopeful. I think both guys know what's on the tape. They're gonna rise, man.
I think they gonna get it then. No guarantees. Right. Boxing stuff happens,
but crazy. Hopefully they take care of business when we get the rematch. Well,
I hope neither fighter looks past particularly Deontay and Ortiz cause Ortiz hit
him with some fucking bombs in that first fight and had them hurt man.
And he recovered. He did recover. He recovered and stopped him.
What a crazy record. That guy's guy.
He's like 39 and Oh right. No,
40 39 knockouts. 40 wins. One draw.
Fuck. 39 knockouts. No two does to fight.
Yeah. One draw and one decision to um, uh,
was it Brazil? No, no, no. Brazil. He just knocked out stubborn. Right.
And then he came back and knocks to Vern out in the rematch,
but that's made him pay for going the distance.
Like you want to go to distance with me. I'm like, I got some fun.
Not only that, the way he did it, just defiant hands down,
winging punches that come from Jupiter. Oh, that was like my biggest fear.
Like losing was one thing. But like just getting knocked out ugly. Like,
like my,
my biggest fear was like getting hit with a shot I didn't see or even feel and
then woke up like what happened bro? And hung down like that. What happened?
He was an amateur. No, never thank God, but that was my biggest fear.
Like you can't control that. You can be in tip top shape.
You're gonna have all the mental stuff down, check all the boxes,
and all of a sudden, boom.
If the shower Cove live landed a little bit left or right. Who knows. Right,
right. That's the crazy thing about getting punched. Right,
because in this day and age, bro, they're merciless. Yeah.
The internet is bursal. They're so merciless. It's crazy. When I was a kid,
I was a giant fan of Donald Curry [inaudible].
Donald Curry fought Milton McCrory,
milk McCrory hit him with a left hook to the body and then a left hook on the
chin and I was like, Oh no. Oh no. Mike McCallum, I'm sorry.
He knocked out Milt McCoy with a left hook,
but Mike McCowen the body snatcher hit him with a left hook to the body and then
one up top and the one up top starched him and he went flat on his back.
I was like, no, and I remember I couldn't take it. I put my shoes on.
I went running, I couldn't take it.
And I decided at that point as I was running down the street, I was like,
I am never going to get emotionally attached to a fighter again.
I'm never gonna like put all my eggs and pass. It's too hard because I lost too.
Yeah. It wasn't just, I saw Mike who I'm a fan of, I'm a fan of Mike McCowen.
He was an amazing fighter. It wasn't just that, it was just that, it was like,
it hurt me.
That's how I felt when Roy lost for the first time I was in New Jersey and it
was like a us,
I was still an amateur to USA versus Ireland duel and I wasn't fighting it,
but I was just out there supporting the team and uh,
we couldn't get the fight and then all of a sudden people started blowing me up
and like, cause I knew Roy was my dude. You heard what happened?
What'd you mean? I got knocked out. I ain't getting knocked out, mr.
So I'm like trying to look them, Roy got knocked out where I was. I was,
I was done. Like, I just like, I just dragged, I went to my room, bro,
put the covers over. My head went to sleep and I woke up and I just felt like,
I felt like I lost. Like it was so painful. Like that's my guy.
That's Roy Jones jr. He's super man. He don't get knocked out.
He got knocked down. He was in a nod song. The new Mike Tyson's Roy Jones.
I mean that was when, when he was in his prime,
people don't understand when you would watch him, he,
the way he would just dice guys up.
It's different and do it so unorthodox.
That leaping left hook was crazy flagged though. Oh my God.
It wasn't just the average like, Oh, I'm talking tough. I believe in myself.
He danced to the ring man. He came, he came in a ring and like a tuxedo road.
Hey, I wanted the little Roy. John was duct tape back there, bro.
Like I wanted to do a, Roy did. Yeah, man.
I remember I wrote him a letter and Brad Jacobs,
who's the COO of top rank boxing right now. Uh,
or the sheet CFO, excuse me.
He was over Roy's company's square ring at the time and I remember Brad wrote me
back and was like, Hey, thanks for riding Roy.
Roy's getting ready for Vinny pads. Patsy Enza.
Next time you're in Vegas he wants to meet you and a the next time I ended up
being John Ruiz. I was up next time Roy fought in Vegas.
But like I've been rocking Roy for a long time. He was a fun [inaudible].
That was,
I believe the only time a fighter never scored a single punch in around
[inaudible] literally couldn't hit him. But the way he did it again, like yes,
he had pads, he has a goal and he's looking at the rough like, Hey man,
stop the fight. Yep. Okay. Shrug like this. And boom, boom,
hit him like three uppercuts, fight over. I'm like, who does that? Nobody.
Nobody did it. Like Roy did it. Not in the,
you know when it's hard for people to look back now cause he's not happening
while it's happening. Yup. Well, but when it was happening back then,
you would just go, God, he played a full game of basketball the day of a fight.
Who does that? Nobody does. I can't say Eric Lucas on HBO. Yeah, it was crazy.
Who does that? Nobody. He did amazing shit man.
When he kept fighting,
what did that cement in your idea that that was never going to happen to you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And I hate that he was kinda,
he was one of the ones, I'm not gonna say he was the one,
cause there's a lot of that stuff going on in boxing. But he,
like when I seen that, I was like, dude,
I can't man the Glenn Johnson fight was hard. I was there.
The Glenn Johnson fight was hard because he was stiff, he was stiff.
And that was right after the Tarver fight. He came out with my gold medal on,
I had just got back from Greece and Roy had my metal on it rapping to the ring
and he's got my metal on it and I'm sitting probably like in the third row or
something like that. And he got stars and his two boys who, you know,
they're grown now,
but they were young and they're trying to like get over the little, like,
like barrier to trying to get in the ring. And I remember,
I remember like a couple of hours after that,
I'm walking around downtown and I saw one of Roy's guys and uh, he was like,
I dry come in and Roy was in the back of a rolls Royce and it was just,
just him and it was all dark and he had his head down and you know,
he opened the door and he, Roy kind of looked up, I was like, man, what sub Roy?
He was like, what's up baby? I said, man, I love you man. I love you.
That's all I could tell him. I said, I love you. I've tapped him up,
gave him a hug and then I was it. But I'll never forget that moment.
Never forget that. And it just, for whatever reason, he just,
he just wasn't able to recover, man. And I think, you know, and you know again,
the blue birds. Yeah. You got the people that are,
I knew where I couldn't talk about, listen bro,
you don't get as far as he'd gotten. Not being able to take a punch,
but when you strip off 25 pounds of muscle abruptly, yeah, right.
It's shocks you. You can't, you can't take a punch. Like Bonnie's weak, weak,
and your whole neural muscular system messed up. Excuse me.
No, it's, it's, I mean,
we see it in fights all the time or fighters lose too much weight.
It's terrifying to see that. But to see Roy,
the Tarver fight was hard to watch. The Todd is a great fighter. He caught him.
He clipped him, he hurt him, he knocked him down, they stopped the fight.
He couldn't get up. That mean,
but the Glenn Johnson fight was much more terrifying to me because he banged his
head off the ground when he went out and he went out stiff or one leg was up in
the air. Those,
those ones where guys looks like he's getting electrocuted when they go out.
Scary. Those are the scary ones. And Tarver, you know,
taking out the from Glen Johnson, he was a total total overachiever, you know,
animal lunch pill type guy, blue collar fighter.
But she didn't expect him to do that. Right.
And a lot of people didn't expect her to do it either. But like, you know,
Olympian, you know, like you could see the skillset.
Big left-handed guy.
So I was not like out of the question and something like that can happen.
But nobody saw that coming with Glenn Johnson? No.
Do you think that he just hadn't recovered really truly from the Tarver
knockout? I think my gut, I think it was that a, and then B, I,
I don't think he took land serious. I think he looked at it like, you know,
it was cool.
I'm going to get back with this guy and I'm gonna get back to the top.
I just don't think he took him serious. And Glen, I was his Superbowl. Yeah,
he's a road warrior. That's his nickname. Yes. So he had to get it the hard way.
So I got Roy Jones coming off a knockout to target, let's go.
He came in tiptop shape and I just went over to,
took a series that made Glen Johnson's career.
Now literally you literally know Tarver went on to fight.
I mean all the way up to heavyweight, right?
I mean I think he was fighting fairly recently.
What does it mean he's got a fight coming up?
Him and his son are gonna fight on the same car target, target jewel.
I think in Florida. I don't know the details but yeah,
but he hasn't fought in a couple of years.
I think he's been trying to get a fight. You know,
you'll see Tarver post of like, yo, I'm ready let, and I don't know why
he hasn't been able to get a chance. I don't know. But I got,
I got once I got over the Roy stuff and I'll never fully get over it,
but like I've forgiven to before it hit like it took a minute.
But like I, I got, I got an immense amount of respect for Tarver respect him.
He had to get it the hard way too.
Like he's a guy that didn't really get a lot of respect and love but did,
did so much for the sport and in the sport.
So I've got a soft spot photographer cause I know again he didn't get his just
do but like he pressed his way. Man, he beat a lot of good guys.
I don't think he'd got is just to after he knocked Roy out.
I feel like there was a lot of people that were second guessing it.
If they were saying, well it's just evidence of Roy's demise.
Like wait a minute. Tarver said at the fucking touch of gloves,
got any excuses tonight Roy and then knocks him out.
I mean if that doesn't get people's respect, I mean he,
he did what he was supposed to do even more than that.
Like to have the guts to chase Roy down like yeah, he literally chased him down.
Like when Roy fought Clinton woods in Portland,
Tarver was at that press conference and every fight leading up to the Ruiz fight
Tarver was at that press conference.
He'd have his phone up with his manager on the phone so they could hear what Roy
is saying. Like that takes a lot of guts, bro,
to chase the best fighter in the world that seems invincible. And I say, look,
give me a shot. Like, cause if you lose, that's it for you bro. Yeah.
You know he did it believed in himself.
The first fight was close and the second fight he said what he said in the
beginning like what kind of guts does that take to build it like the whole
world.
And then you got any excuses tonight and even before the knockout buddy McGirt
says something about respect. He said, man, you showing him too much respect.
Maybe he said don't use that word in his corner. He was locked in. Wow.
He was locked in and then went out and knocked her way out. So yeah,
it had something to do with that. But that's not Tara's fault.
Don't use that word in this corner. Never heard nothing like that, but
wow. Wow. Who do you, when you look at the game right now,
who do you think, who is exciting too?
Obviously this Terrence Crawford and Loma Chanko, but is there any,
anybody that really stands out for you? And my little brother,
Chicago Stevenson co-manage him along with James Prince and Josh Steuben. Uh,
silver medalists. Uh,
he's getting ready to fight his first title fight coming up at featherweight.
Um, he, he stays focused, which I believe you will.
He's going to be on top for a long time. Um, [inaudible] female Lopez, uh,
he's a young up and coming guy. He's getting ready to fight.
Reportedly Richard me sometime in December. Possibly. He's a young guy.
Obviously Terrance Aero spends, um, they have to fight, right?
It's tough, man. It's tough. But for a fan, listen, God, listen,
I want to see it. But if you're on his side,
I see what they're doing and honestly, what are they doing?
You can't even be mad at it. Well, Al Haymon and those guys over there,
they got all the welterweights. So if you don't, if you're not, you know,
if you don't really like the other side or if you feel some type of way about
ESPN and top rank and you know that Terrence is wanting this fight,
why not make him wait a year or two and let your guy arrow,
Spence try to clean out the whole welterweight division.
Now he has Shawn Porter coming up and that's not going to be easy fight for
either guy. And I and I respect it and got a lot of love for both,
but they're trying to squeeze them out. So they're looking at us like, yeah,
I hear you. You want that fight. But we've got bigger plans.
I'm gonna let my guy, you know, a mass, you know, a bigger following.
He's got a big following in Dallas and Jerry's world. Jerry Jones is behind,
you know, Errol Spence. So that's what they're,
that's what they're doing right now. And as a fan, I don't like it. Um,
but as a businessman I get it. I understand what they're doing. But from Europe,
like what you're saying, you know, to your point, my only thing with that,
and I've told both guys this,
like you can't say that you're the best and you may feel like you're the best.
You may tell yourself you're the best,
but you really don't know if you're the best until you fight the best.
And that's my only thing with boxing as a stance today,
like social media, man,
social media tells a lot of lies. Like it's some young guys coming up.
I'm not gonna name any names, but it's some young guys coming up who,
who have a lot of potential could possibly beat the guy,
but they're not fighting anybody. But yet they'll go to social, you know, I'm,
I'm the man, I'm, I'm next Floyd's going, I'm next. And you get social media.
You right man. You huh? Come on man.
It's something called box wreck or fight facts punching.
And now you go to the search punching first last night and you gotta be specific
with box rec because if you're not,
if you miss bill a letter in the word in the name, it won't pop up.
So get the name right first and last,
and then all of a sudden the record pops up first fight to whatever their last
fight was and then you can cross reference the guys they beat.
Oh this duty beat was 20 and Oh, click on click on that dude's name. Ah,
this dude ain't fought nobody. So his 20th Oh really?
Ain't a real 20 and old and you're hanging your hat on.
The fact that you beat that guy,
it's a lot of that in the game and guys aren't willing to test themselves.
Now listen, it's a place for it building. It's a place for getting seasoning.
I'm not, I'm not a fan of rushing like I'm not, you know,
that's not what I'm saying. But at a certain point in time,
if you're going to say that shirt the best and that you're the next Floyd and
that you, regardless of what way class you may be,
you gotta test yourself against the best because guess what?
You don't even know how good you are. You won't know until you face another guy.
Like I said this the other day when I was in the UK, I said,
everybody wants to be allying when there's no lions around.
You can be aligned in the, in the, in the company of hyenas,
but when you're facing another lion,
now we're gonna see what you're really working with. Yeah,
everybody's a soldier when there's no Wars going on, but when a war happens,
now we're going to see what you made them.
I would just like to see at a certain point in time, I get making money.
I get the political stuff that's going
on, we don't like, but at some point in time,
if your pupil is going to say that they're the best,
you got to face the best so we can really see who's who. Now,
if you're not about that life and you're like, dude,
I'm just trying to make as much money, but at least amount of risk,
I suppose I respect, respected and uh, at least you made your intentions clear,
but you can't have your cake and eat it too. You can't say you're the best,
but not fight the best. You gotta face the best at some point in time.
I like what boxing does in that the managers dictate who the fighters fight and
that they do build their fighters up correctly.
And one of the things that bothers me about MMA is I think there's some really
good young fighters who get ruined because they get thrown to the wolves too
quickly and they wind up getting their confidence shattered.
They get knocked out maybe when they shouldn't be.
They're finding a caliber of fighter. They're not prepared for,
for every one fighter like that. You know,
there's always the arguments of like a guy like Jon Jones,
youngest ever light heavyweight champion, like youngest,
every UFC champion fights a legend. Mauricio Shogun who, uh,
when he was a 22 or 23, I think it was 23 years old,
opens up with a flying knee, hits him in the face,
beats the fuck out of them and takes the title for every John Jones.
There's a guy who's coming up that may be,
could have been a world champion but didn't get managed correctly.
And the UFC doesn't give you any options. The doc says, Hey,
you want to fight Camaros, man? Okay, here's your fight. This is a tradeoff,
right? So fans get the big fights, but, but, but you know,
in the wake of how many careers, you know,
that's the trade off the fans get the big fights.
But I don't think we necessarily see the highest caliber of fighter fight,
the highest caliber of fighter with the,
the best case scenario at all times. Do you know what I'm saying? I don't,
I don't think we get to see the most out of some of these guys cause I think
that if they were managed, if there was,
it was a ton of different promoters around and you weren't locked in any
specific sort of an organization like the UFC has.
I think you could see more managers saying, you know, Hey man,
you're not ready for Robbie Lawler. Hey man, you're not ready for this guy.
We're going to take this, this fight on a regional level.
We're going to build you up. We're going to get you to, you know,
1516 [inaudible].
Then we're going to start challenging some top 10 contenders and some at your
place. But this way you'll have seen all the looks.
You'll have seen a great wrestler. You've seen a great striker or you, you,
you fought a Moitai champion, you fought a jujitsu guy.
You know how to handle all these different scenarios and an MMA.
That is part of the problem is that it's not just your hands.
There's so many different scenarios that you have to deal with.
It's like the JG Wentworth commercial. I need my money now.
That's what it is. I tried Dana white, like, bro, I need to get paid now.
Right now you had you ever come in, I can't find a better match up.
Let's make it happen.
The UFC will throw a guy on his UFC debut against a guy who's a world-class
contender and you'll watch them get lit up like a Christmas tree.
And I'm not a fan of that man. I'm a fan of again, seasoning.
Make sure you're ready. But it's like in boxing man and not everybody.
Like if you look,
the light heavyweight division is one of the hottest and the most willing
divisions for guys to face each other. [inaudible] yeah,
it is division. They spit them out. Woo. They spit them out. Yeah.
Um, but like as you look at some of these other divisions, it's like, man, dude,
like how many posts can you have where you're saying that you're the best,
but yet you're refusing to fight the best.
But there is a thing about social media though,
where these guys can self promote in a way that's never really been available
then it's all good. But like just don't expect everybody to buy it, right? Well,
as a champion, you, you value that title the best.
So and also as a, I still care about it then,
then we're not going to bother you. But when you,
when you bring that light on yourself right now we want to, we want to have you,
you know, backup what you're saying.
Well that's one of the reasons why the UFC takes this strategy.
They give a young fighter fight you like, you think you're a beast. Okay,
we're going to throw you into the beasts.
You might have four or five professional fights and occasionally guys get
through and you realize, wow, this guy truly is special.
That's the philosophy of the UFC is put together the best fights all the time.
Like every car, they want murderers, fight and murderers.
And I see that from a promotional perspective. It's brilliant.
And from a fan perspective, it's brilliant.
But from a person who values a fighter's development, yeah, I would go,
Ooh, if I was a manager, I'd go, don't take that fine. Don't take that fight.
Not yet. Not yet. Not yet. It's like a Tyson fear.
Get ready to fight out of volleying. Uh, another tone fight. Right.
People are like, Oh well listen, while Eileen is a good fighter,
we'll see how good he is.
But you also have to look at like Tyson fury and everything. He came off of,
you know, drugging and boozing and you know, just on the brink of disaster,
personal disaster. Like give him a couple of fights to get the rest off. Right.
So when he does face Wilder, it's an even better fight. Yes. Why? Why is,
why is water find Luis or T listen, give it some time.
So it's not that we're trying to like sell these fights individually,
but we're selling the package deal. Like support that you support these guys.
Yeah. You want to see their rematch. Yeah,
we're going to get a better fight if you let them go through the maturation
process, you know, Wilder's trying to, you know,
stall and wait for Tyson fear to get what he needs to get out of the way.
Tyson's trying to get a little bit more rust off so it could be a better fight
than it was the first time. And sometimes fans don't see that.
And like you said, to your point, we as broadcasters and writers, we have to,
we have to educate the people a little bit. They still may not like it,
but at least we have to present the facts and say,
this is why we're seeing this right now. So you do a fantastic job to try, man.
I try, I try. You know, I'm, I'm trying to, you know,
just continue to just keep, keep on keeping on man. But again, I gotta dude,
I got a great team and I had a great team at HBO. Again,
I still can't believe they're not in the business and I still keep in contact
with a lot of those guys and then we'll be have it at ESPN, man. It's just,
it's just different man. Like our lead producer, like I said, Mike McQuade. Uh,
like we like in past times I would just show up to the, to the,
the site location on a Thursday night, a fighter meetings,
production meeting on Friday, Saturdays, the fight,
I go home Sunday now.
Like we have a production call the week of a fight on Tuesday and probably an
hour long.
We're constantly texting and sending emails of information and you know,
either Joe test is, you know,
challenging us in this area or Tim sending an article or I'm sending something
or Bernardo sending something or you know, Mark crew,
like we're growing like w it's just on another level right now.
And I think that's why people get the production that they're getting. No,
you can tell, you can tell,
you can tell in the actual fight itself while you guys are doing the commentary
that you guys are buttoned down and locked up. I mean it's,
it's all your T's are crossed and your I's are dotted. So performance business.
But yes, it is. You know,
you're approaching that the same way you approached your fight career.
I don't know any other way. I don't know any other way.
When you're doing it though, I mean you're, you're 20,
how many months out of your last fight when you're doing it though,
there's gotta be a itch. Sometimes this gotta be itch.
It's not going to go away.
How did you just accept the fact that you have that itch?
[inaudible]
is there a part of you that thinks like there's a 10% chance you might make it
come back? Like, do you have a number in your head? Yes.
It's whatever percent it is.
And then I wake up and I started hearing a pop pop boom, boom.
My knees and my back and they're like, I'm not as wired. Tired. That's why.
So that, that discourages me quick man. Um, do you still exercise?
Yeah, I gotta stay fit. Yeah, I hit the bag. Uh, I haven't done a boxing thing,
but I think I'm gonna do it. I, it's weird,
like part of me has done it for my whole life, so I'm kind of burnt out.
And then the other part I'm like, dude, I don't want to miss it. Like the wait,
I want to do something else. So I'll do a lot of, you know, spinning,
spinning classes, spin classes.
I take spin classes but then also have a Peloton at my house.
I have the Peloton treadmill and the Peloton spinning bike Varsa climber. Um,
I love that thing. So I do, I do a lot of, you know, alternative stuff,
but I think I'm gonna get back in and because a great way to just keep the
weight off and, um, after two years,
I think I'm ready to start hitting the back again. Man,
Mike Tyson says he can't, he said he doesn't want to.
He says if he starts hitting the pads again and hitting the bag, well,
even at 50, he says his ego starts firing up again. It starts thinking about,
I feel, I'm not saying Richardson, legendary train out of Philly.
He put it to me like this, like, like last year sometime. Um,
he said somebody asked him like, man, you think like,
we interviewed him for my doc and um,
my boy Deontay he was the director. He said, listen,
do you think Joy's ever going to come back? He said, you know what? He said, ah,
I don't think so. He said, you got to realize Android hasn't,
hasn't lost in a long time. He said,
as soon as you start looking at retirement like an opponent,
I think he's going to be just fine, and I never looked at it like that before,
but then when I finally understood what he was saying,
it's like that's what I'm fighting against right now.
So like just like a regular, I study retirement, right? Like I said earlier,
the highs and the lows, the good, the bad stories.
Just like when I fight in a fight, I got my supporters and I got my detractors.
I got people saying, man, amen. Stay gone bro. Way to get out on top.
I miss you, but man, Hey man, I'm happy you did it like that.
Then I got people saying, Oh, he's coming back.
All fighters come back just like I was in in a real fight.
I wanted to win that battle. Right? This is a battle that I want to win too.
So I'm looking at retirement like an opponent right now and,
and my last, you know,
I don't know how many years I've been doing pretty good against opponents.
So I like my chance. I like your chances too. And I,
I think you are very important for the sport.
I think you're an important shining example of what's possible, what's possible,
both with your accomplishments and also what's possible with walking away with
you all your marbles and tight man. So thank you for everything, brother.
Thank you for doing this. Appreciate it. Really appreciate it. I'll go.
Thank you, ma'am. Bye everybody.
Great.
[inaudible].